Chilson and non coffee enthusiasts.
Coffee,
coffee,
noninclusive.
Well I drink it every day and I like
coffee,
but I've got a doctorate a little bit,
you know,
I've gotten copy mates and the hazel
nuts.
I've got to do all that stuff.
Uses Jazz Stevia.
No,
no,
but may I is good.
Yeah,
please.
It's stronger than sugar so don't put it
in like you would do sugar,
but it's a completely natural available
everywhere.
All sorts of health food stores and
whole foods carries it.
It's a uh,
just a plant based sweetener.
Not Sugar.
Not Bad for you then give you the DAB.
This doesn't,
um,
doesn't fuck with you.
Like aspartame does.
Some people don't like the taste of it,
but I like it.
And the fact that I can get away with it
where I can drink and I know there's no
sugar at all.
I like it a lot.
Are they a sponsor?
We do an a plug right now.
I don't like it.
I could say I know about safe sex.
We don't even sell it.
So I'm a fan of it.
So here,
here's my theory on coffee and I think
this is true.
If if coffee wasn't around and I
discovered it and I sat you and Jamie
down and I slid a cup across the tape
and go try this guys,
I want,
I want $50,000 from both of you.
I'm going to build this coffee.
Taste this.
You'd go,
you're out of your mind.
You want to give me a dollar?
They'd go,
no,
no.
Not only,
not only am I going to sell this for a
profit,
I'm going to put sprinkles in it.
I'm going to put it in a fancy cup.
I'm,
I'm gonna.
Mix whipped cream on top and sell it at
300 percent profit.
You could just get out
and tell you.
Well maybe,
I mean a very small niche market maybe.
I mean,
it's not like it's going to be
everywhere.
It's not bad,
right?
That Stevia is good.
It's not bad.
It's Kinda like a little bit of a
bitterness to it.
It doesn't taste as good as sugar,
but for me it's a good compromise
knowing that there's no,
nothing negative about it,
but I'm going,
this is how you start your show.
I like this.
No Big Internet.
You just turned it on.
It's not necessarily share the man.
No one else could pull that off really
good.
They just need to do it.
If you just didn't worry,
if everybody just didn't worry,
they would just do it this way.
I suppose you're right.
So whatever we talk about today is,
there is nothing going on.
No,
I mean it just seems like it's just
nothing happening.
It's just an average Monday,
a couple of coffee drinkers here.
I,
uh,
you know,
we're all trying to figure out if
they're going to sell,
sell or not.
Right?
And I'm on the other side of the fence
from a lot of the reports.
I'm going,
God,
I hope so.
What a cool thing.
I mean,
they can sell the work they put in the
risks.
They built this interest in that.
The ultimate thing you want to do with
the business day one,
when you sit down to start a business,
you want to create something so cool.
Somebody else wants to buy it,
so I'm on the other side of the fence.
All of these reports were coming out
like this was going to be earth
shattering news.
I'm good.
This is going to be great.
This is if you like them,
if they've done something for you and
you're cheering for him than cheer that
this goes through.
Particularly if you retain Dane,
and that was the other part of the
report was that Dane was gonna.
Stay on.
Well,
that's relevant.
There's not another.
There's not another guy alive that can
run that and that's not some nice
statement to Damon Damon.
That's just the truth.
Like you can't go to a library and check
out a book on
fight promotion.
You can't go to any college and major in
promotion.
You either know it or you don't.
Yeah,
it's.
It's difficult and it requires all day.
Like Dana's working all day,
like people for people that don't.
I'll call him at like 1:00 in the
morning and he just got off the phone
and he's doing deals and he's making
things happen and he's trying and he's
obsessed with it.
I mean I got really does love the
business of putting together fights.
We will.
I'll,
we'll talk randomly just in the middle
of nowhere about fights for hours.
He just loves to talk fights.
He really is a big fan and obsessed and
not burnt out yet,
which is amazing because the amount of
hours that guy puts in and obviously
he's making a shitload of fucking money,
but it's still the amount of hours that
he puts in.
You would think he would be cooked by
now.
Yeah,
you would.
And I know what you mean.
One am is a good time to get ahold of
him.
I was in Brazil.
He called and woke me up.
I was doing the ultimate fighter.
He walked me as 4:00 AM and I grabbed
the phone and he was talking business
right away and I just said,
Dane,
I got,
I'm not here.
Right.
And whatever I agreed to right now,
I get a pass because if you give them
your word,
that's it.
Right,
right.
Whatever I agree to does not see I'm out
of it.
It's 4:00 AM.
And he goes,
Oh man,
it's 4:00 AM.
And I said,
yeah.
And he goes,
dude,
I thought it was only two.
I'm really sorry for calling.
But he was,
he was serious.
He was serious.
And so it was like,
okay,
I get it,
man.
If you're working on.
And it was the office line,
it wasn't his cell line.
He was at the office and I'm going,
okay,
well look,
if you're going to work for him in
Brazil,
what time is that in America?
That's got to be 10.
They're not that far ahead.
Where are they?
They're there for six hours.
I was in Sao Paulo,
so it was still,
you know,
he's in there grinding.
That was a ballsy move.
Have you to do the ultimate fighter in
Brazil after you had talked mad shit
about virtually every legend that ever
came out of.
Yeah.
And to understand.
Thank you for saying it,
but it's also relevant to understand how
big MMA is over there.
You get away with that here and there's
gonna be some pockets that know exactly
who you are,
but it's going to be just that pockets
in Brazil.
It's the number two sport behind soccer.
Everybody knows.
And I had a,
I had armed security.
We went everywhere in bulletproof cars
and uh,
and one night I'm the guns came out and
whatever bravado you think you have or
you think you will have when the guns
come out,
you find out it's not true.
You're scared.
What happened there?
This is an actual move,
like there's a name for this and it's
very common in Brazil,
but we were going to traffic and a guy
cut in front of us and then what they'd
like to do is cut in front of you,
slow down and they get boxed in.
They jump out and rob you.
So when the guy swerved out,
we're in three lanes,
traffic.
There was nobody else on the road.
So when the guy cut in front of us,
security knew right was going on.
They pulled their gun out,
my wife was in the back and she was
sleeping.
She was laying down,
she had her feet across me and uh,
I woke her and I said
he got his gun and uh,
there was an exit right up and the guy
swerved over as quick as he cut in front
of us,
took the exit was gone.
Nothing happened at all.
But in that moment you find out when the
guns come out,
what ever macho is you think you're
going to have in that situation?
You don't have to,
were you think in like,
why did I talk all that Shit I've just
said,
yeah,
I had no way to know I was in the car.
I mean,
I think they were just getting ready or
at least the,
the security thought they were just
getting ready to rob us,
you know,
it had.
But yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
that's true.
You know,
Getting.
Can nobody here take a joke,
am my job,
but ended up being a great time.
It ended up being a really great time.
The ultimate fighter just isn't
generally.
I had the opportunity to have them,
but you build lifelong relationships.
You know,
you stay friends with those guys.
You watch them being vulnerable.
You watch them putting their whole life,
everything into it.
These get leaving their families.
The first ultimate fighter I did,
we had two holidays.
I'm counting thing.
A Halloween is when I realized that
isn't a holiday,
but if you have kids that's a big day.
Skies leave their kids.
They don't get to see them dress up and
then we had thanksgiving.
They don't even get a call home.
One guy had the birth of his first
child.
He did not get to call in and check on
his wife.
I mean it's.
It's a big deal.
What goes on and they are very strict.
I don't know why they are joe.
I realized that for reality TV that,
that,
that turmoil is build something,
but I'm kind of looking at going,
you know what?
Let's do this little nine to five deal.
Send them home,
give them their cell phones.
Let these guys just be regular guys.
People talk too much.
They tell too many secrets.
They,
they explain what's going on to talk to
press.
They give inside scoops and will only be
revealed,
you know,
I promise you this won't be revealed
until the show goes to air.
There's a lot of fuckery that goes on
with,
with people that are on reality shows.
That's what they're trying to overlay.
A funny word fucker.
He's one of my favorite words.
Great words,
but yeah,
there's truth to that.
But you are your appearance on the
ultimate fighter in Brazil with vangely
to it sort of changed like vandalize
public opinion right now is very,
very high.
Like people like him again,
and one of the reasons why they like him
is because he got fucked over by the
Nevada state athletic commission,
hardcore.
They banned him for life,
for missing a drug test,
which I just think is fucking tyranny.
I think that's straight bullshit.
I think that that is a fucking horrible
miscarriage of justice.
If you think the guy was doing
something,
then you find him and you,
you,
you banned him for the amount of time
that you need to based on if he was
guilty.
That's it.
You don't get to do life that's fucking
crazy to do,
to be so callous to show that you are a
governing body and that you are taking
care of the future of these athletes and
supposedly protecting them from other
athletes that are cheating or from from
whatever other nonsense,
whatever other illegal activity might be
going on,
and to take that position of power and
into flagrantly abuse it in that way
where you're just,
you're,
you're openly showing
them that you don't give a fuck about
them.
You don't care about their career,
you don't care that this is the only way
they have to make a living and you just
going to ban them for life because they
missed a drug test.
So let me,
let me give you another side of this
too.
Vandelay never told his side.
Vandelay got pissed and he yelled and he
went to,
created all of these things,
but he never just sat down and told his
side calmly.
So here's vandelay side,
and when you hear this,
you're going to,
you're going to side with vandelay.
Here's what happened.
I was the first guy ever tested,
uh,
in this random out of competition
testing,
so none of us knew what it was.
And you have to take that time into
perspective because now guys understand,
look,
you get a knock on the door,
you must,
you must comply.
But I was the first one ever took,
we'd never heard of this guy shows up.
Vandelay was to be the second one
tested,
but did it,
did it test.
In hindsight,
I shouldn't have tested.
I'm not even sure they were within their
rights.
And this is relevant.
They show up.
The guy has no id,
absolutely no identification of who he
is.
I think that's a problem to start with
you then.
He's a huge.
He then wants to take me into a back
room which ended up being a janitor's
closet,
not sanitary,
a backroom at the MGM grand.
He takes me in there where I must
disrobe and present to him my penis
because he,
w he watches,
you know,
that's a very private thing.
And the ID,
he wants to see your dad and if there's
a look and they need to.
I understand now and I think a lot more
of us do to that you're going to have to
get naked and do this so you get wisdom.
You got all these weird things going on
at that time though.
That's a weird thing that we're in the
back of the mgm grand in a dirty closet
and I'm presenting to a stranger who
refuses,
not only doesn't offer id,
refused to give id and I tried to take a
picture of the son of a bitch and he
told me I could not do that.
Why I backed down and did it to.
I don't know.
I just accepted his authority,
but in hindsight call me.
I'm at.
Yeah,
exactly.
I should've.
I should've,
but I was caught off guard that had
never been done before and I'm kind of
just going along,
but I am caught off guard by this.
He then wants to stick a needle into
your vein and draw blood.
I'm in a back,
unsanitary room.
Anything I've ever learned in school.
You don't do things with intermediate
needles.
You don't take.
This guy has no idea.
He's not in a lab coat,
doesn't look the part at all.
Uh,
so now I presented myself naked to him
and now he's got a needle in my vein and
I'm signing paperwork that I haven't had
time to read.
So when he goes to now understand,
I speak English,
we at least speak the same language.
Also take into consideration that kind
of got in fairness,
perfectly nice guy trying to feed his
family,
but in fairness,
what kind of person says,
I want to go around and collect people's
Pii.
It's an interesting kind of guy.
So I'm with.
I'm with an interesting character to
start with.
Now I'm naked.
Now he's poking me with needles in a
dirty backroom at the MGM grand.
He leaves there and goes to test
vandelay.
Well,
when you take everything I said into
consideration,
nobody knew about random testing.
Nobody knew about a sudden.
Nobody knew anything about this,
that out of competition,
silver vandelay to go,
hey,
I don't know who you are.
You're not presenting it.
I don't fully understand you.
That's fair.
And vandelay talked to them and said,
you want me to sign a contract?
Get my attorney on the phone,
show me what this thing says.
You know,
he's Kinda going through the p and the
way the story was told us that vandelay
just turned and ran.
Well,
that wasn't true.
He stood his ground and talk to this guy
for awhile.
He said,
get on the phone with an attorney.
Prove to me who you are.
He did all of these things and then
finally said,
look,
I got to get to a press conference.
I'm leaving.
Got In his car and drove right to the
MGM for the press conference and I
didn't have this backstory at the press
conference,
but that's what vandelay did.
So when the story came out that he
turned and bolted out the back,
that's not true.
He stood and talked to the guy.
He tried to reason with them.
Vandelays never told calmly his side of
the story and that's his side and that
makes a lot of sense.
Even in today's standards.
That makes sense.
But back then when no one knew that drug
testers could be showing up,
and once they showed up that you needed
to present yourself naked,
that you needed to accept,
uh,
you know,
that they were going to draw blood.
Yeah,
man vandal.
He had the right to say no.
Call my attorney.
I don't know.
I don't know what's going on here.
And the guy wouldn't show id that's
relevant as very relevant when they
banned him for life.
It's crazy.
Come on.
No,
you,
the way you describe it.
I didn't know it.
Was that okay.
Yeah.
I never told him what all he's done is
yell.
And I've always thought,
no.
Wait,
vandelay timeout.
You've actually got a really good site
here.
Come and tell it now.
Under today's standards is a little bit
different.
Um,
because we know what's going on and we
know there's,
don't know that some crazy Internet
troll can't pretend he's a Usada guy.
Show up.
Drag you into a bathroom and take a
picture of your Dick.
Exactly.
And they will and won't let you won't.
Let,
won't document who he is.
We'll let you just take a simple picture
of him.
Well,
that's insane that they don't have to
show Id.
I mean that.
That's tyranny right there.
There,
there has to be some sort of due process
and the athletes are already in a
disadvantageous position in the first
place.
I mean,
they,
they can be fired.
They mean this,
this random thing that just shows up,
which I don't want.
I don't know what kind of
constitutionality or what,
what kind of legalities involved and
just randomly testing someone's bodily
fluids.
I mean,
I guess you sign a contract agreeing to
that,
but boy,
that feels.
That feels shaky.
Yeah.
It feels like that can be disputed.
And to your point,
you now do sign a contract and you agree
to go into this pool,
but back then we did not,
you know,
I was,
I was the first guy.
Vandelay was the second guy.
Uh,
we both ended up with suspensions,
but it was different.
It's like,
well,
Hey,
wait,
if you're going to do this,
you got to tell us or you or you got to
tell me right on the spot,
but you've got to at least prove who you
are.
And I would imagine the women must have
women testers come out to watch them,
but I don't know that for sure.
You know,
you hear this thing about these tsa pat
downs and the women feeling violated.
We haven't heard any women's say that
yet,
but at some point,
you know,
I just think there's a fine line there.
They might have to be a little bit
careful.
Well,
vandelay had his lifelong suspension
thrown out.
Right?
So now he's still in limbo though
because they haven't decided how long he
gets suspended.
And what they've done is.
And by the way,
how many years ago was this when this
took place?
Three,
three years ago.
So the man has not been able to earn a
living in three years doing what he does
best,
which is fight.
And he is,
he's a legend.
I mean,
if you're going to have a mixed martial
arts hall of fame and you don't include
vandelay Silva,
you got a bullshit mixed martial arts
hall of fame.
I mean,
you talking about a guy who was the
pride champion for a long time,
you know,
had incredible fight,
legendary fights and his beloved.
My point was when you and him went at it
on the ultimate fighter,
his fucking popularity crashed because
you made them look foolish.
He looks silly.
He wanted to start a fight with you.
He was trying to intimidate you and it
wasn't working.
You're like,
please don't touch me.
Please don't touch me.
And then finally you wind up taking them
down and just like Jesus Christ,
like,
what the fuck are we doing here?
Yeah,
it was,
it was really weird.
And uh,
you know,
trying to explain that to vandelay on
the set,
what was a battle to and,
and vandelay walked out on the very
first day.
He demanded an apology.
He said,
yeah,
he comes in front of everybody.
Cameras are rolling.
We're about to pick teams.
So it's got all the guys there and his
way of taking the moral high ground was
to demand.
I apologize and if I don't then he
quits.
It's like Vandelay,
why'd you put yourself in that position?
I'm not gonna apologize,
but why would you say you're going to
quit now?
You have to quit.
Now.
You have to walk out.
So he does.
When I,
when I call his is he walks off the set
camera,
stop everything.
They put us in the back and,
and I'm telling the producers I'm not
going to come out and apologize.
Call Vittorio Vituro.
Come out and do it.
We'll have torn a plane.
That's how we're going to solve this.
Now we can't call it a uh,
yeah,
we get.
We got to work this out with Angela.
Could you please a pledge?
I said,
look,
I want this show to go forward,
but this is the storyline.
The storyline is the bad guy has come to
Brazil.
Vandelay gets to be the White Knight on
the Horse.
Let's continue the script.
So I had to talk to vandelay and a
private room and I had explained that to
him.
Like Mandalay,
I get what you're doing here and you're
trying to be the good guy,
but guess what,
you are just let me go do what I do.
Okay.
You will come off as the knight in
shining armor and I'm okay with that.
You're not okay being the bag.
I am.
You Go,
do you let me do meet the scripts
already out there.
That's why we have this job.
And I couldn't reason with him Joe.
He really did not understand it.
And he does.
He's saying,
Oh,
you know,
on and on and on and uh,
I,
and I broke it down to a zoo.
Yeah,
he was doing that.
I was breaking it down and he's telling
me how I'm doing everything wrong and in
my sportsmen ships off and,
and my promotions.
But,
and I said,
stop.
I said,
George St Pierre Left Brock list or I'm
the guy.
I'm the highest paid guy in the UFC
right now.
I'm not the guy you tell how to promote.
I'm the guy you cop and I was just
trying to level with them.
I'm the guy you copy.
That's the reason that,
that all these things are happening.
And uh,
he,
he agreed with me on that.
He goes,
I understand that,
but I don't like how you did that.
I don't.
Like I said,
great.
Then here's what we're going to do.
We're going to do this show.
Okay,
I'm going to to be the bad guy.
And then we're gonna fight.
And if you're so sure you're going to.
I mean this,
this,
this is your moment.
And he was ranting on me for the
andersons thing,
I,
I said,
did you see how that fight worked out?
Okay.
I took my punishment,
man.
I had to eat it all.
It's an embarrassing thing,
but I did it that,
that's my payback for that.
You and I are on a separate deal.
You're trying to insert yourself in an
Anderson fight.
Anderson already took care of that
matter.
Okay.
He handled his button,
but now you've got to handle yours.
And it was just a weird thing and we
just,
we just couldn't.
We just couldn't come around.
Well you are an interesting guy to get
into these altercations with because
you're very logical and because you can
say a bunch of crazy shit and not take
it personal and I just don't think that
he has that kind of mentality.
His mind,
his
depression,
but that's him.
I mean he just wants to throw down and
so he expected you to butt heads with
them and you're like,
hey man,
come on.
We're here to make some money.
We're on TV.
We're going to promote this zoo.
And it just,
there was no fucking way he was.
I mean he just came into this with this
idea that he was going to go shoot the
buck style that he was going to get in
your face and get angry and maybe you
guys were brought on the set,
you know,
but you just weren't having it.
I wasn't having an end,
but I also understood this vandelay I
want to be the bad guy and this is my
brand and this is what I'm doing.
I'm the only guy on that side of the
pool because I'm the only guy that's
willing to be so I'm the biggest healing
in the business right now,
and I know this.
If I come into your country by myself
and not speaking the language and you
team up,
you gang,
you team up on me,
I become vulnerable.
If they see me as vulnerable,
they're going to like me.
I don't want to be like you're ruining
everything.
And I knew if we,
if push came to shove,
they're going to take vandelay side.
I'm going to come and short,
but in the world of public opinion,
I'm going to come out on top,
which I've worked very hard that I don't
want to be on that side.
That's not where I'm trying to be.
I'm down there,
okay,
and I'm all by myself,
which means I'm ruling that part of the
market and I was pleading with him when
he was trying to get in a street fight.
I remember even saying to him,
please stop like Vangelis,
please.
I don't this.
I don't want to do this.
Let's get a date.
Let's save it for the octagon and he
just,
he,
he saw that as weakness and as soon as
he saw the weakness,
he started picking on me.
He's like,
vandelay,
if you pick on me,
I become likable.
I don't want that.
That's what this is all about.
Okay,
I'm down there.
You guys be down here.
Okay,
I'll be the nerd sitting at the end of
the pool by himself,
but that's still my end of the pool.
Will you approach this in a very
calculated way,
which is very rare for people when
they're doing promotion for fights.
You know,
there's shit-talking,
there's,
you know,
people say I'm the best ever.
They Brag,
they do all sorts of different things,
but it's very rare that they purposely
put themselves in one position and you
did it on purpose and you,
you are the only guy that really had a
vision.
You like,
look,
everybody out here is doing it one way,
but there's a way to do it completely
over the top,
but you obviously
had skills to back it up as well,
but you were completely over the top and
you cherish the role.
Like when you took the microphone,
went
Anderson Silva,
you absolutely suck.
Like the whole place started cheering.
It's like,
ah,
he's.
He's gone straight pro wrestling.
Like you're the first guy to ever do
that,
right?
Yeah.
Let's cut a promo.
I mean let's tame attainment.
You know we are an entertainment and I
firmly believe when one fight ends,
the marketing for the next fight begins
right then,
right?
That are paying attention the most.
When I hear people tell you all the day,
who do you want to fight next and you're
giving them an opportunity where your
softball on them right down the middle
and they say,
anybody in their message what they,
what they want to be related.
I'm not a bully.
I'll take on anybody.
I'll take on all comers.
I don't care.
I get that,
but that's not what people are hearing.
If you say you don't care,
how can you expect anybody else to?
If you tell the whole world,
I don't care who I'm fighting,
well then how in the hell can a fan
care?
How can they care about you?
You got to care whether it's a personal
thing,
whether whether it's a career move,
whether it's the title of whatever it
is,
you have to care and there has to be an
answer.
If you don't care.
I don't care.
Nobody's ever gotten a job job by
telling the guy,
interviewing him,
I don't.
I don't care.
Well that I can't hire you.
I just can't hire you.
Yeah.
Especially if there's someone who does
care.
Now there's a mention of when,
when I tried to get in your podcast
today,
if you'd have said,
hey,
are you free on Monday?
And I go,
no,
I don't care.
You Go,
well then I'll just call somebody else
jail.
I need a guy in the studio that wants to
be here.
What you do?
I want to be here.
Well,
I wouldn't worry about that with you if
you said I don't care.
I said,
but like good sales in a weird mood.
This is going to be a fun podcast.
Fair enough.
But there's a.
there's an
psychology that goes along with fighting
and one of them,
one of the things that happens to people
when they're preparing for a fight,
and you could speak to this,
is that there's a sort of a compulsion
or a,
a,
a feeling that you would like to avoid
thinking about the fight as much as
possible.
There's,
um,
there's a natural sort of attraction to
just putting it aside.
Let's like,
let's just not think about this.
Let's not think about this at all.
Let's only focus on the task at hand and
when the task in hand is over,
then we're going to take a break.
And when a fight is over and the relief
has hit,
a guy like to shift gears and go
straight into promo mode.
Sometimes guys have done it and they've
done it and it comes off artificial and
it comes off clunky.
It actually hurts them more than it
helps them.
Like it seems like it takes a very
specific type of personality to be able
to pull that off.
Correct.
Directly.
I think that's fair.
Yeah.
And I've seen some guys do it and I.
Ben Rothwell comes to mind.
Yeah,
well we'll have some pocketed and even
an awkwardness or something to see
there.
It's not a total miss.
It.
It does come across as pocket and
scripted in.
My only advice to Rothwell is if you
have a pocket of statement and you're
not ready for the followup question,
drop the mic and walk away.
Here's your bit.
An exit stage left.
And yes,
it's very hard.
It's hard to say something you want to
say.
And when the followup question comes,
you go back into being yourself.
That's very hard.
You've got your look.
If you take a character,
you finished the character until it's
done.
And if you're stuck.
Walkaway.
Yeah.
Like Daniel Cormier,
when I interviewed him after he beat
Rumble Johnson,
John Jones,
get your shit together.
That's it.
Perfect.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was perfect.
So Dan,
let's stay on.
Daniel.
Daniel this week was in one of the.
It was a very weird spot.
So Daniel comes in.
He's not just a good guy of mma.
Joe,
he's the great guy.
Daniel never will somebody meet that guy
face to face,
but what did your never will?
What's amazing is how much he gets
booed.
That's my point,
but everybody hates him.
You then have John Jones who is a real
life heal that wants to be loved and for
some reason the crowd used to be against
him and now they find out he's really
find out who he is.
They love it.
They're in.
Why do they?
They love him more.
Now that he's keeps fucking up.
Daniel Cormier was at a press conference
with Jones and Jones says,
I've been sober for three months,
and the crowd goes crazy.
They then shift the camera over to
Daniel.
The whole crowd starts.
We hadn't even said anything.
They all start booing.
Daniel takes a mic and goes,
you guys are cheering that.
He's been sober for 90 days.
I've been sober for 36 years.
They boom again.
They hated it.
So Daniel gets put in this weird spot.
He brings that momentum into this fight.
He then becomes vulnerable.
His heart's out there.
He shows the world that he takes the
high road.
He says,
I think that Jon Jones made a mistake.
I've made mistakes before.
He starts telling these personal
stories,
his heart that he's in tears.
Everybody loves him.
All of a sudden he goes into the fight.
Anderson,
boom,
people.
People love the appreciation.
He stepped up great middle,
all these different things.
Daniel gets beat or rather beats him.
The crowd boos and the Daniel tries to
address the audience explaining himself.
It's like Daniel,
a couple of rules and politics.
First off,
you steer into a problem of a crowd
wants to boot.
You don't ever ask them for their
approval.
You take the mic,
you hold your belt up high.
You thank them all for the percentage of
their ticket sales that you got.
You tell him to shove their opinion up
their ass and you walk away.
If you're explaining,
you're losing.
Do not explain yourself.
Do not say,
I had to do what I had to do.
There's such A.
I'm tired of the misrepresentations
representations and fighting.
It comes all the way from the top.
We hear that the fans want to guys that
are going to go out there and bang,
well,
that's not true.
The biggest draw in the history of the
sports,
George St Pierre,
he never went up there and banged with
anybody who finishes it is a very
handsome man.
He's very marketable.
I will concede that,
but the bottom line is that's not
necessarily what people want and the
exact same game plan that did is what
lester did five minutes later and
everybody loved it.
That that's not what it's about.
What they decided they want to see
Anderson when they weren't upset that
they were on the ground there.
Whereas if they weren't on their feet
because they knew that's where I
understood could knock him out and they
decided they were going to cheer for
Anderson Cormier.
I should have just told him to shove it
up their ass and they'd be stuck.
Yeah,
but that's not him at all.
But he wants to be liked.
He wants to be like
Joe,
I understand that,
but that's not the way to be.
Like the only way to be liked as him to
beat the shit out of John Jones.
I mean that was the only way because
right now he's got a title that let's
just be completely honest about what it
is.
It's not a title that he beat the
champion to get sure he had to take it
away from the champion.
And the public recognizes that and while
John Jones may be screwing up a lot,
he may have all these problems outside
of the octagon,
inside the octagon and no one has been
able to best him.
He's amazing.
And because of that,
because of that,
people are on his side because people
love winners.
They just do,
they love Mike Tyson when he was in his
prime and you know,
even when he came out of jail for
alleged rape,
he claims he never did it.
I don't know what happened obviously.
Um,
but when he came out of jail,
they were still rooting for him.
I mean,
here's a guy who,
if you have daughters,
I have daughters,
you know,
if you have a girl and you hope,
boy,
the worst case scenario is my,
my daughter finds herself in a position
where a man wants to physically do
something to her that she doesn't want.
People didn't give a fuck.
They were like Mike Tyson's back back
and he's still looking angry and he's
rip now.
He's been doing prison workouts and
there's something about a guy who's just
a bad motherfucker that people love.
Yeah,
and there's a.
there's a thing where they know that
Daniel feels that there's a thing where
they know that Daniel knows that John is
the guy who won the first fight,
that John is the legitimate linear
champion.
That John is the undefeated fighter and
literally the only undefeated fighter at
that level.
There's no one.
I mean he has one loss to Matt Hamill,
which is a bullshit disqualification
from a dumb fucking rule which said a
million times.
Nobody's more angry about that.
Then you,
Jon Jones is not as frustrated about
that loss issue.
Our madness.
It's the law,
the law.
The rule is madness and it only exists.
I talked to big John Mccarthy about this
extensively only exists because the
commission was ignorant.
Sure.
They didn't understand that those bricks
breakers,
it's not that hard to break a fucking
brick man.
Seems crazy,
but it's really just not.
Especially when they are spread wide
like that.
But John Jones has that aura of
invincibility about him.
Now,
if he fought rumble,
Johnson rumble,
Johnson head kicked him into oblivion
and we see John was toes curled,
you know,
lying on his back,
snoring which absolutely can happen to
any human.
Then the whole thing would change and I
think the walls would come crumbling
down and if John did a press conference
and said he was 30 days sober,
they will start booing them.
They wouldn't give a fuck.
I think that's fair.
Yeah,
you're right.
America does love success.
Fans are front runners.
They've got the right to be,
but yeah,
historically that is how it worked and
we're talking about rumble Johnson and
John Jones.
Man,
we got to get that match up.
We fuck they fucked up.
I mean,
the whole thing is fucked up and that in
that,
that hasn't happened because he's in
real danger with clover like that.
That air of invincibility was taken away
from him by,
by um,
Daniel Daniel beat him and he broke
Daniel,
beat him down,
took his back and choked him and you
could see rumble,
just having a real hard time with the,
what was going on in that fight.
He had given his all and that first
round he had hit danny with a bomb,
like literally took him off of his feet,
sent him flying across the octagon.
But Daniel is tough as fuck.
And he survived.
He gutted it out and then he imposed his
superior wrestling and wound up winning.
So we lost a lot there because that
fight was supposed to be Jon Jones and
Rumble Johnson.
And then Jon Jones Rumble Johnson would
have been fucking epic.
That would've been really interesting to
see what happens when a guy who hits
like rumble connects with a guy like
John.
And especially back then when we didn't
know what would happen,
we know that Josh Koscheck had beaten
him,
that he had real hard time in the later
rounds when he was competing at one 70.
But we also knew that there's no fucking
way you should have been at one 70 even
when fall [inaudible] 85.
It was kind of the same thing.
He came out like a bat out of hell and
then faded.
And then we assumed that he also missed
one 85 against veto by seven pounds.
Yeah,
I mean he had a notorious problem with
his weight.
So we kind of attributed a lot of his
failures to that.
And we see him at heavyweight beat the
shit out of our lawsky break as John the
first round,
just Tulum for three.
And we say,
well,
okay,
well rumble at two.
Oh five is the fucking man.
We missed that.
Ms Dot opportunities.
Yeah,
I agree.
And you know,
when you,
when you bring up Rumble Rashad who
trained with both John Jones and rob
says,
rumbled beats him.
Now rumble only does have one problem.
He is a front runner.
He does fade a little bit,
but that's a big storm that he brings,
you know,
rda fights that way.
He started Amanda Nunez fights that way.
Her own teammates.
We're saying,
look,
if she gets into the second,
third round,
I don't know about this,
but she's going to bring a storm in that
first round Ou and I don't think Misha
can survive it.
I talked to Dustin Porsche,
he trains with Amanda and he said that
he goes,
well,
if it gets into the later round,
she,
you know,
her percentage goes down.
He said,
but I think he or she's going to come
out and she's going to put her foot on
the gas,
empty the tank.
And the first,
I don't think she's going to be around.
And he's right.
Isn't that fascinating?
Those fast twitch muscle fiber fighters,
those ones who explode,
the really dynamic ones,
there's a,
there's a fucking given a take to
everything.
Sure.
And those,
those ones,
they just don't survive into the third,
fourth and fifth round with the same
pep.
So.
So let's back up.
I made a note here on that Jon Jones
thing.
Did you follow the whole johnstones
drama and the most recent one?
The only post drama?
Yeah.
Was that he had a press conference the
next day.
Did you follow that press conference at
all?
I saw the crying pictures of Jamie sent
them to me.
I went to that press conference and
there was a couple of takeaways,
and this is all speculative,
but for this doesn't make John innocent
at all.
Well,
John's guilty.
They've got,
they've got the stamp.
Let's guilty,
but his actions were not that of a
guilty man.
Historically,
guilty guys go bury their head in the
sand.
They tried out run this thing.
They get with their legal teams.
They show up at the hearing.
They hope for the worst,
for the best.
They get the worst and they deal with
it.
John face the music.
Twelve hours later he came through the
hotel.
His whole life's pulling apart right
now.
I imagine he didn't even sleep that
night.
He comes to the hotel with the fans.
He comes into the media pr one.
One says,
you read a script that was written for
you and you exit the stage instead.
He read no script,
he took every question asked of him,
and that's just not what a guilty guy
does.
Not understand that he's guilty in terms
of data,
but what we care about,
his intent was he trying to get over on
somebody,
was he trying to hide something?
His actions would represent that he did
it,
but here's the problem with the press
conference,
Joe,
when you hold a press conference,
you have,
you have one goal in mind which is to
win over the media and that they say
nice things about you before you do go
home and bury your head in the sand.
Secondly,
you want to break something.
You want to get something out there to
get ahead of the store.
That's the whole reason you show up at
these things.
The only car that he had to play is what
did you test positive for?
That was the only thing we didn't know
and they refuse to reveal it so that
that was a little bit weird and where I
was sitting because I've been in John
spot in here was the thing that happened
with me.
We're,
we're talking about John,
this whole thing is going on with John
based on a test that took place on June
16th.
The reason that relevant when I went
through my thing,
I was he tested positive for semesters
in blockers.
Those don't really have anything to do
with anything.
They don't help you.
They're silly.
I think you might've just revealed
something.
Yeah.
He tested positive for two estrogen.
No one else knew that.
There you go.
I'm revealing.
You broke personal information.
That's what we're doing here though.
Right?
Wow.
But this is like,
this is like the only way that anybody
could find that out is if you talked
about it.
Boom.
It's out there.
Right.
And that we're doing here,
aren't we?
Creating some news.
It's a big news day,
but let's say,
but here's The relevance and let me tie
myself into this.
When I went through this job,
I had something selling in there.
In fact,
I had an estrogen blocker.
I have something silly in there and
everybody forgave.
I was.
I was going to be suspended,
but fox,
every I was fine.
Everybody looked good.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
we changed the rules in the test and
everything was fine,
but what I had to live with,
what only I knew there was another test
out there,
but the results hadn't come back yet and
I didn't know what that test was going
to show.
I know what it could have shown.
I know what it should have shown,
but I know what the other test could
have been,
should have as well.
So you're sitting there hoping,
how good is this damn test?
That's all you're thinking about.
Well,
we,
you and I had a conversation.
You're the guy called you on stage and
I'm blowing you up.
You're like,
hey man,
I'm doing a show.
Can I call you tomorrow tonight?
I will stay in capital letters tonight.
I need to hear from you tonight.
Yeah,
I remember the exact words.
He said,
well,
you know,
we were wondering how stringent these
new tests are.
Turns out they're really good.
Turns out it's a pretty good test.
Turns out it's not like the old,
a one,
800 requests a test that costs $99.
Okay.
There's a reason this ca,
this test is 40 plus grand,
but the thing that I'm,
I'm,
I'm wondering,
does John have another test out there?
If he does it doesn't mean it's going to
come back,
but that was the same spot I was in.
There was a shoe that could drop for me.
It did for him.
Is there another test out there?
And if there's not,
the facade
has got some explaining to do.
If you're telling me a guy that's got a
track record,
the tested positive for cocaine going to
fight in the biggest fight of his career
and the last time you tested them was
one month before the bout.
Then it was.
Sod has got some explaining to do,
but there's more to the story now.
What do we hear it?
Does he pass his,
the end up in the spot?
I don't know,
but that's,
that's the piece that's still missing.
Well,
there's one aspect to his,
uh,
test is positive test that people are
saying could possibly play a factor and
it's a supplements that he could
possibly have been taking something that
like,
this is what happened to 10 means this
is what happened to um,
allow Ramiro where they get a supplement
and it says it has a bunch of stuff on
it says you look through the
ingredients.
Okay.
Creatine [inaudible],
we're good,
we're good.
But then when you run it through a lab,
it turns out there's a bunch of other
stuff in there too and that's why it's
so effective and that's why it sells.
So it is possible that that could be the
case.
We don't know yet because then if that's
the case then John has to give them all
the supplements that he was taking and
then they have to go to a store,
buy them independently,
test them and verify that these
ingredients were in not just the
bachelor,
the hands them,
but also in other batches.
So it's not like he doctor did show some
stuff in there.
Sure.
But estrogen blockers are usually when
people are getting off of steroids,
right?
When you're coming off a cycle,
it's a blocker.
You know,
men don't want estrogen anyway,
but it's a blocker.
It's not going to.
So as far as that substance goes,
and that's all that's all he's going to
have to live with.
You're not going to have to explain how
they work for someone who doesn't
understand what an estrogen blocker will
do if you up your testosterone than your
estrogens has naturally ups.
And guys don't want estrogen.
So if you're a guy,
you,
you take a blocker that can block that,
bring it to you,
you won't get a,
you know,
I'm trying to think of a word Guy Gasta.
I can't even.
I can't bitch.
Tits is all that comes to mind.
I can't think of the word guy.
I'm a guy.
I'm more closed.
Guy Got a go.
At any rate,
it can stop some of those things.
So that's the speculation.
And the reason that that's on the list
is they find that that's a way they can
catch you after the fact,
Hey,
if we missed you during this cycle,
we can catch you here.
Well,
it's not just that.
The reason why they take it after the
cycle is because you get hypogonadism,
your,
your body stops producing testosterone
because you took exoticness
testosterone.
That's right.
And so the.
To restart it,
they'd take this stuff,
these estrogen blockers.
That's right.
Yeah.
I tested positive for an estrogen
blocker and it was that exact thing.
Same thing.
They banned testosterone.
I went on something called Hcg.
She'll return your testes back on and
then you have to clomiphene,
which is by definition an estrogen
blocker for that same thing,
but it can also help get your body going
back on testosterone.
So they're band.
John's got a problem,
and again,
this goes back to the press conference.
He said,
I have not taken anything new that I
have not taken my entire career.
So somebody gave him a follow up
question.
He quickly realized what he just said.
And he goes,
wow,
I do have a new supplement company.
I have taken some new supplements.
So he realized,
put himself in one point needed to get
out of it.
The supplement company then who dropped
him immediately came out with a press
release that do not put this on us.
We don't have anything to do with that
and we'll turn over any samples you want
so that that's.
That's the downside to holding a press
conference is if there's anything that
commission hates,
it's when somebody isn't honest with
them.
Well,
if there's anything who a hates and it's
with Lance Armstrong found out it's when
you deny the scientific accuracy of
their test,
that's the risk with holding a press
conference.
That's why most legal teams will tell
you,
go home,
be quiet,
rewrite right to remain silent,
execute that.
Show up at your hearing date,
gets sworn in,
say your piece,
and then go ahead
about your life.
How does John not have a trusted
handler?
How does John not have someone who
realizes that you don't just have like
a,
a high level athlete?
You have arguably the greatest light
heavyweight of all time,
who has not,
in my opinion,
reached its potential yet I think John
has massive potential outside of what
he's actually shown because when he
moved to Albuquerque and we saw that he
was training all the time and we saw the
most recent footage before he fought
over in St prue waste power lifting.
He looks fucking huge.
He's dedicated.
His eating clean.
He's making these instagram videos of
all this healthy food he's eating.
We're assuming he's getting the proper
rest.
All the other things we're assuming,
get the wild man.
Days are gone.
He's still got the wild man's mind,
but now he's gonna approach this like a
real competitive athlete.
Here's my question to you.
When someone is wild and talented and
impulsive,
just a wild motherfucker like Jon Jones
is.
Is it even smart terrain,
that guy in Ken,
how can it affect him?
I mean,
is it a positive thing to read them in
or is part of what he is and why he's so
good and why he's willing to open with a
flying knee on a shogun was the first
fight.
The first fight for a title,
what was he?
Twenty three,
24,
20.
He opens up with a flying knee on,
you know,
one of the legends of MMA,
former pride champion or fry pride,
a Grand Prix tramp champion and UFC
champion as well.
You'll,
you'll look at a guy like John in the.
The way he competes in the way he's.
He's so creative and wild in there and
impulsive.
It's almost like that's a part of his
success.
I fully agree.
And historically I could bring up
athletes where that is true or they go
sober where they go straight and narrow
when they find God,
whatever these things are in,
they changed something that yeah,
the dominoes start to fall.
The problem is when you've got a wild
man like John,
he's in a box and it's a loose box and
he's having some fights,
but usually that continues to escalate
so he kinda needs to keep himself right
in that framework.
And the bad news is it usually just
keeps get.
It just usually just keeps pushing.
So that's a very important.
That becomes a problem.
That's
a very important point where people
escalate things like billionaires want
more billions,
right?
They want islands now.
They want fucking jets and spaceships
and with
a pro athlete or a wild person who's
doing crazy shit,
they want to do more crazy shit.
They want to drive 150 miles an hour.
They want a man,
but it just seems like whatever the fuck
you do,
nerf everything around him,
you know,
by up the town.
Fucking have three guys that he trusts,
followed him around everywhere and make
sure that he doesn't eat anything that
he's not supposed to eat.
Don't take any pills you're not supposed
to take.
Don't.
Most of us don't drive.
I mean that was his biggest problem was
getting behind the wheel in front of
everything else he was doing was like,
John,
you gotta get you gotTa.
Get a chauffer,
you got to get uber.
You can take a taxi.
Don't get behind the wheel.
That was the most of his problems.
He had some other ones,
but that was the most of it.
If you just took him out of the driver's
seat.
A lot of this doesn't exist.
Yeah,
a lot of it doesn't exist,
but this most recent one obviously does
and the like.
Yeah.
He had those.
The two major car accidents,
we had that beautiful Bentley and slid
it into a tree and then obviously the
one where he crashed and that woman and
left the scene of the crime,
which was horrendous.
He survived that though.
You know,
he vibe that he came back and the urban
st prue fight.
He Won.
They beat a top six guy on short notice
and then this happens.
And to get positive on something as
small and innocuous as estrogen
blockers.
Yeah,
I agree.
So you go back to that open state
approved fight,
single worst performances of a
performance of John's career,
single worst by light years.
They.
You break it down a little further.
He won the grappling,
he won the striking.
He won every round.
He did it.
He did it back off.
You didn't get tired.
He was stronger.
And that was on a bad day.
I didn't think it was a bad fight.
I,
you know,
everyone says the single worst
performance.
I have a great deal of respect for St
prue and I think [inaudible] is a very
dangerous guy.
He's very explosive.
His left power kick is extremely strong.
He has a nasty left hook.
He's a southpaw and he fights odd.
He has a very odd style.
I would agree about opens.
I think your assessment there is fair
and I think his stock went up that
night,
but when I'm watching John,
I'm going,
okay,
this isn't that.
This is a rusty John.
This is slow or the outputs a little bit
down.
The bottom line is on a bad day,
he left with a world championship on a
bed.
That's how good he is.
The other side of John,
you know when you're talking about the
car wrecks or one more time about the
cocaine or what he's going through now,
and again,
this was my takeaway from the press
conference.
The biggest takeaway was John won't own
anything and it's like John,
at some point you can't do the routine
about.
I don't know why God put me in this
spot.
This is,
I don't know why God put me in the spot.
Everything happens for a reason.
I'm going to come out better.
On the other side,
it's like John,
you're acting like you got diagnosed
with diabetes or cancer or something.
You know that you're the victim.
You weren't a hit and run.
You did the hidden and you did the
running.
That was your fault on the cocaine
thing.
You didn't say,
somebody slipped me a mickey.
You said I was at a party in Brazil,
a rolled up 100 and went down to the
tip.
That was your fault.
Now you're in a jam here for two banned
substance in.
You're still not taking response and you
think God's put you in this spot.
It's like John said,
you put yourself in this spot and at
some point if you're the baddest dude in
the world and you are,
you gotta man up on these things,
you got to man up and go,
Hey,
I'm guilty and I how exactly it
happened.
I'm going to try to figure that out,
but I'm definitely guilty of Sada does a
good job.
I trust those labs.
Let's get to the bottom of the jail.
Son In public relations is what we need.
We need a need,
a little earpiece.
You put in John Jones ear,
you sit behind the screens.
You have a monitor here you go.
No,
no,
no.
John,
this is not.
Just stop.
Stop right there.
But no more victim.
No more victim role.
You stand up like Tony Montana and that
fucking restaurant.
You're looking at the bad guy there.
Say Hello.
There it is through her bag guy.
Yeah,
I like to party.
Bitch,
I fucked up.
I took some shit.
What?
So what supplements would have
testosterone blockers or estrogen
blockers excuse,
but none that I've ever heard of.
And again,
but,
but if you're there,
but if they boost testosterone,
estrogen blockers,
apparently the is more of an effect of
testosterone.
How's it work?
I've never heard that.
No,
that could be true.
I think of myself as kind of an expert
in this field from being on the wrong
side,
but on both sides of it.
But,
uh,
I've never heard of that.
I can't imagine why supplement company
would do that.
And this supplement company wasn't like
Tim means it's company or Yo El Ramirez,
they came out with a press release
instantly,
so do not put this on us.
Let us know what you need from us.
We'll drop it off at the lab ourselves.
Jamie,
see if you find this online because
someone told me about it this weekend
and I never got a chance to look at.
Someone said that there are certain
things in supplements that you know
could have been sold by a company that
would allow you to test positive for
these very things.
See if.
See if you could find that in,
in relationship to John Jones is test
because I remember someone talking about
it and I said I gotta remember to look
this up.
What it's owned there.
Only those two chemicals.
The only exists like in a pharmaceutical
world,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
So it's not like it's a root or
something and you know.
And then what exactly they got upon me
that that's still coming out.
But that was one of the things,
again,
to go back to the press conference and I
think,
I think John did more good than he did.
I think it was kind of a good thing that
he came out.
He showed courage.
He didn't read the script,
he answered all the questions,
but the bad was he didn't tell us what
he tested positive for the bad news.
Now we stuck with speculation.
If he wouldn't come out and tell us
exactly what it was,
you and I wouldn't have to gas and go to
the Internet and Springfield and
speculate and rumors is which.
Which you don't need.
I don't know why he held that with
understanding who god is going to tell
us.
Tell us.
I don't think they know.
No,
I don't.
I really.
I think if they're gonna charge him and
they keep getting sued,
have they're going to charge them and
they are within the.
Oh,
that I'm going for breaking one year.
Like medical information.
You'll take it out of it's medical
information.
I suppose you're right with Hipaa,
but this doesn't fall under that.
The commission's going to bring charges
against him for certain supplements.
They're going to bring him in,
require that he's there,
they're going to have to address it.
Then he's going to say his piece.
Look,
I took this.
I didn't think I'd get caught or I don't
know anything
about it.
That's.
That's a route.
Guys go as well,
but the bottom line is it's going to
come out.
I thought he had a good opportunity to
tell us what it was and perhaps give a
guess as to how it got an assistant.
If he is going to take that path.
The outright denial path.
That's not a great one historically,
but some guys taking,
if that's the route,
he's going to go to an outright denial.
Tell us what it is.
Oh yeah.
Here we go.
Go
a substance tests warning.
Bodybuilders and other athletes objected
to substance testing should never use
this product unless first approved by
the validating organization product may
cause a drug test result called false
positive urine or blood.
What does.
What is this stuff?
Oh,
is this the company that John Uses?
Oh Shit,
guys.
Clean.
Second.
Second is taken to just keep the fucking
guy.
Oh my God.
This is hilarious.
When you go to this gap website and you
know,
I don't know what's in there.
I don't know if this is a good company.
I know nothing other than what I'm
seeing right now.
You're looking at a guy in their photos
that's fucking clearly on steroids.
Fucking clearly test digit.
He's not testing.
If that's it right there,
Jack Guy,
that massive mountain of muscle is not
on steroids.
Send me that shit.
Send it to me.
Box it up.
I'll fucking.
I'll promote it for a month for free.
If you can get that guy to look like
that and test or test negative like that
guy's not on Anna.
Draw 50 and fucking tests.
SIP,
sip innate and every other fucking thing
in the book and gorilla come and
whatever the fuck he's on.
That's a whole that you should not like.
I hate to be the guy.
Why?
Why is the white guy so skinny in the
background?
Look at that photo again.
I looked at Greg Jackson's brother a
little bit.
Doesn't mean what's that white guy doing
in the background like that white guy
has a skinny neck and you know,
it was it kind of traps or he's flexing
them but they're not really that
impressive and he's in the back like
looking at this black guy.
This is like some cuckold type shit.
That's what this is.
This black guy just doing curls and he's
about to fuck the shit out of his girl
and the other guy is like looking
through the curtain like man,
I don't even know what to do here.
Like look at his face.
He's not lifting.
What is that guy doing in the back?
He's got like minimal chest development.
He looks Kinda scrawny.
I would suspect you have something to do
with the company or his father does a.
that's generally how these things work
out at the bizarre.
That's a book that is,
that's a bizarre choice.
Like why is that distracting guy over
that gentleman shoulder?
Like one guy's looking at me like,
fucking look,
I'm good and boog got shoot is working
good man.
I'm getting big Bro on clean.
I've got a dog tag on.
Probably never been in the military,
just sort of look to wear dog tags that
are going to war.
That's like a dog tag with like,
it's like be dazzled.
See it's got like tuning.
Not I see has got legs on the outside
edge of it.
It's Kinda like a little fucking
rhinestones and shit.
It's a black dog tag too.
It's not even a real dog tag is what?
This is a weird fucking photo shoot.
I don't understand it.
So there it is.
So there are directions for tested
testogenix let's,
let's go to that directions.
I want to find out what I'm supposed to
do to get like that guy.
Is this the company that John's.
Whether this is just what we brought up.
Oh,
this is just the company on training and
non training days.
A dietary supplement take two to three
tablets with breakfast and the other two
to three tablets with lunch every day
after six weeks of continual use.
One month break is recommended.
So it's a cycle.
It's this test.
Okay.
Let's.
What are the ingredients?
Let's go all the way up.
What do we got here?
Hm.
Vitamin E,
vitamin B,
six,
magnesium,
zinc,
selenium,
chromium tested gin,
mass.
Strength and size.
Formula Three,
b hydroxy five.
And Dro Sten Sten Not Steve [inaudible].
Seventeen one.
Okay,
a three.
One H indol three.
Okay.
Yeah,
these are tricky little things.
Beta sit toll sterl from solely other
vegetable oils.
Okay.
I don't know why I've told me that.
Uh,
I provide a bunch of bullshit after
that.
They always throw.
I'll go wild.
Yam Root Twenty five milligrams.
That's nonsense.
Wild yams or where they get testosterone
from,
they actually extract testosterone.
They make it out of wild yams.
So like when a company throws in like 25
milligrams of Wild Yam,
what are you doing?
Like you just trying to pretend that
that's,
that's significant.
Your Wild Yam root.
A lot of goofy stuff in here.
Ginseng extract.
Why do you have Jensen?
Yeah.
Well come on.
He's not taking.
What do you think?
Challenge,
jealous was waking up and taking this
stuff.
Why not?
If it's.
If it doesn't,
if Beta alanine works,
it's got 500 milligrams of Beta alanine.
That stuff's legit.
I mean a mute me.
How do you say it?
Mucuna parenthesis,
pure insists is extract that's been
known to boost a human growth hormone,
I believe,
but I'm looking at all this stuff that
he's doing.
I might be wrong about that.
I don't even know how to say that word.
I don't even know if he was officially
taking this particular supplement.
I just,
when I googled,
uh,
that company and just say this is the
first one that came,
of course,
right?
Yeah.
So this is just by that company we don't
know,
but none of these things are estrogen
blockers,
so it doesn't make sense unless he got a
tainted supplement,
which again,
and this is not the fault of the
company,
happens all the time because the way a
supplement company works,
like say if you wanted to buy a creatine
or something from a company,
you buy it in bulk from a supplier and
that supplier,
you might be in China or who knows
where,
and they mix these things up and they
use the same Vat.
Like that was the Anderson Silva Story.
That was his alibi,
was that he was buying liquid cialis and
he was buying from a company that also
sold steroids and apparently according
to people that know him,
that is actually what happened,
which sounds crazy.
Very well.
And he and he had three.
He had three.
He tests positive for three things.
So maybe that knocks one off the list,
but yeah,
I hear you.
There is some confusion there.
Yeah.
I mean that story is bs,
but I hear what you're saying.
There is,
there is confusion in there.
Tim Means was innocent 100 percent.
Yeah.
And Yoel Romero.
And they ruled that.
That's not my opinion.
They ruled the World
Ramiro.
I mean,
you want to talk about not passing the
smell test.
That guy is a goddamn freak of nature.
I've never seen a guy he out of all the
other freaks,
he makes the other freaks look.
Sure.
And Frank Mir appear.
That's a,
that's a weird one to even their own
science.
They're confused on Frank Mirs because
there's metabolites were so low where
they're going,
what?
Look,
you passed here,
but you did it here.
For your metabolites to be this low,
you would have had to have taken it six
weeks before,
but we tested you.
They're there.
They are even confused on their science.
They're,
they've,
they've admitted that they go at the
shows up.
We got to do something with it,
but we don't.
We don't understand how you had this
reading and frankly I'll tell you
everything I did.
I'll tell you everything I ate.
I don't.
I don't know how this works.
You give me the answer and they're even
confused themselves.
Go ahead.
This,
this shouldn't be.
It is.
We've got to deal with it,
but it take the supplements,
the test,
the things that he's.
Frank hadn't taken any supplements.
That was the other thing he said he
fought in some,
some different country.
He goes,
look,
and everybody made fun of him for this,
but he was just being honest,
catering and he knows how he said that
he now that the headlights made them
look bad,
but frank was just being Kennedy because
look,
the only thing I've done different.
I was in this different country,
some kangaroo meat for the first time.
Everyone teased him,
but he's going to ask me.
They asked me,
have you done anything different with
the IOC is telling athletes we're food
in certain parts of the world in China
and in Russia in particular to not eat
the meat because if you eat the meat you
could potentially test positive.
Right.
Depending on when it came it.
So frank offering them that was just,
you know,
he got teased for it,
but he was just being candid.
He might be right.
Yeah.
I mean he,
he might've got some unscrupulous
kangaroo meat.
Yeah.
And Frank's always been an open guy.
He was on testosterone.
He wasn't one of the guys that tried to
hide it like the other guys.
He went and asked for the tea.
Frank.
So a pretty straight up guy.
He's an open book and it's not all great
stuff.
I mean,
he'll tell you this.
I'll tell you what frank says.
I didn't.
I tend,
I believe him.
Yeah,
I do.
I do as well.
Yeah.
He's just an.
He has also a career of being straight
up to start being deceptive now over
something that doesn't really
necessarily make sense,
you know,
after losing the Mark Hunt like that.
This doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense.
Um,
the testosterone thing,
that is a,
another thing that I feel like was
medically very irresponsible the way
they handled it and also that they
didn't allow guys to take something like
an estrogen blocker or something that
Hcg or something that restarts your end
to,
consist of,
but yet they allow these guys to fight
and scheduled flights just a couple of
months after getting off testosterone
therapy.
So you put these athletes in a very
precarious situation where you're
dangling this gigantic financial carrot
in front of them.
You know,
you're saying,
hey man,
we got to fight.
You know,
you're going to make x amount of dollars
is going to be awesome for you.
But here's the kicker,
no more testosterone,
so all this stuff,
it's been making you feel good and
making your camps go better and allowing
you to recover faster.
That shit's out the door.
So now you have to deal with not just
your 37 year old endocrine system,
which is fine,
but a 37 year old and inconsistent and
that needs to be restarted and you can't
restart it.
Yeah,
that's right.
And,
and,
and they do put them in a tough spot
too.
And I would be curious if this was ever
tested in a court because they put them
in an interesting spot where a guy gets
advice from his doctor,
which you're supposed to listen to and
he has to cross reference that advice
with an athletic commission will time
out a second.
We're not talking about illegal drugs
here.
We're talking about legal medicine,
FDA approved medicine that I'm taking
appropriately and in conjunction with my
physician and you're telling me I can't
take it.
And that even happens with the common
cold flu and that they'll be in some of
these silly things.
And Anderson Silva,
so he popped for that steroid,
but two of the things he popped for were
over the counter.
One of them is a sleep aid that sits on
the shelf next to Nyquil.
None of us knew was band until he got
flagged for.
Well,
scratch our head guy.
Maybe that's on the banned list.
What is a sleep aid provide like as far
as performance benefit?
That's.
So everybody likes to go back to that
go.
This doesn't help my performance.
That's,
it's not a performance test.
It's not a steroids test.
It's not a drugs test.
It's a banned substance test.
And that's where they go way out of
bounds.
Sometimes I think back to the,
the,
the Chinese gymnast where they stripped
her metal,
uh,
in 2004 and kicked her out of the
Olympics forever because she had a
billionth of a trace of Ibuprofen which
has a street name of advil.
I'm going,
this is silly,
you know,
this is silly.
Good.
Well,
it's an antiinflammatory in that would
help performance you go,
that's a good thing to take some legal
to take a legal thing that you've found
that can help you.
Why would you take anything that could
hurt you?
That was another thing that John came
out.
He was so adamant that I took nothing to
help my performance.
I'm going,
John,
I don't know why that's the high canon
of bad things you don't want to be
associated with.
You took coke,
which is a felony and can kill you,
but now you're standing on the moral
high ground that you didn't take
anything that could help you.
That's just weird.
That's weird.
It's a weird way to phrase it.
If you say,
I didn't take anything that would help
my performance than yc saying no.
Say what the fuck you took and why you
took it.
Sure.
Say what it is,
but we only white Joe.
Why would you take any of it's a
supplement or anything else?
Why would you take it if you didn't have
a reasonable expectation that it helped
your performance because you're not
taking it for that.
Then you're taking for the opposite.
It has to be one of them.
What are you taking it for?
Something else in life.
Maybe you've taken it for anxiety maybe,
but that doesn't make any sense with
what he was taking it.
But you know,
I mean,
look,
Anderson was taking a liquid.
Seattle's because he likes to party.
I mean,
why?
Why do people take different
things that are not,
that have nothing to do with athletic
performance?
They take it because there's a desired
result.
Um,
but what I'm saying,
if you're trying to fall into the scope
of a medicine,
well I can have an estrogen blocker
would be,
or testosterone.
Those are classified as medicine and
then maybe it can call it drugs all they
want.
That's medicine under the FDA.
You can't become a medicine unless you
can reasonably prove that it's going to
help a patient.
You can't be a doctor.
Give somebody something that brings them
down and makes them worse.
That's malpractice.
Well,
here's what I'm saying is I know for
while he denied that it would help his
performance,
like,
well,
of course you took it to make you feel,
but whatever.
I'm drinking coffee right now for the
caffeine.
That's just what it is.
That that helps your performance and you
were one of the first people to tell me
that there's a very specific amount of
caffeine that you're allowed to have,
so you would take an for them.
You wouldn't trust a cup of coffee,
right?
Well,
yes,
that's true.
That is true,
but I just think that's ridiculous.
One to.
They say that to now.
You'd have to be tested your bodies to
all these different things,
but they say that two cups of coffee in
a 15 minute period will make you test
hot.
Now you'll only test taught for about 15
minutes because caffeine wears off so
fast,
but yes,
if somebody was to come in right now
I've got three different coffees in
front of me.
I could be above the limit on that.
I'm sitting here going,
Oh,
I'm getting jazzed up to do a podcast.
I'm not sure that that.
I'm not sure that that relates,
but the rules are the rules.
I'd be cheating,
but is that out of competition since it
has such a short life,
like if you came in here is because when
John tested positive for cocaine against
Daniel,
it was three weeks out,
so it was out of competition.
So it wasn't like he was fighting coked
up.
Right?
That's right.
And there is two different sets of
standards there.
Uh,
and caffeine gotTa,
if you're out of competition,
you must be fine.
Advils and you know,
we talked about advil or there is some
that are only band in competition.
There are a lot out of competition and
then there's some no nos forever,
but that's where it starts to get
confusing.
And then the way they've handled it is
to go,
it's on the athlete.
He was like,
well,
okay,
fair enough.
But athletes,
particularly,
fighters are the lowest form of society.
You're the government.
You can't just put it on the athletes.
It's got to be your,
the government.
You're operating on the taxpayer's
dollar.
You've got offices,
you're making the rule.
You take some responsibility to.
Yeah,
no,
I agree.
And I think especially when you're
talking about a medical issue like this
testosterone therapy issue,
I mean it's worked itself out.
That does,
did settle in time.
They allowed it to just play itself out,
but I think a lot of guys got fucked
over and I,
I hate to,
um,
be a Vituro apologist.
Uh,
but because I've been such a,
I was such a fan of trt.
Veto loved him.
Oh my God.
And we all did.
It was such a free is great.
When he,
when he fought bisping and rockhold
he's,
we'll kick in people and don't be t RTV
tour was fucking terrifying.
But vituro when he fought Weidman,
I remember feeling when he went into the
octagon and I saw him bouncing around
and it's loose,
skin was moving all over.
His body is like,
wow,
this guy's fucked.
Yeah,
like his body is fucked.
This is not a regular 37 year old guy
who was in shape who hasn't taken
anything.
No,
this is a fucking world championship
caliber pro athlete whose bodies been
just compromised,
massively compromised.
So,
I mean,
he's rebounded.
He looked much better now,
but God damn you look terrible
and acg is so important for any doctor
will tell you.
If you go on testosterone,
you've got it.
Then go on Hcg.
You got to turn that,
turn that back on.
He didn't have that benefit.
The rules came in.
He had two different flags and he just
wasn't ready to go down that path,
so he literally stopped everything cold
Turkey opposite of the advice of his
doctrine.
I've never asked him about the.
I just know his doctor would have said,
look,
this is what you need,
and he goes,
I'm out.
There's no room for error here.
They've changed the rules.
I'm out
as crazy as they.
That could affect them longterm,
Joe.
It,
it certainly can,
and certainly the beating that he took
could affect them longterm and the
beating.
There's a big factor of having
incredibly low testosterone and we have
very low testosterone.
When he went into that fight there,
there would be a possibility.
I actually see that's not true.
I should.
I should recant that because Weidman got
in his face at the way in and was saying
you took because he tested at 1200 and
Weidman tested it three and he was like,
what the fuck is going on?
How do you have four times as much
testosterone is me and I talked to
Novitsky about.
I was trying.
I was like,
please explain to a moron like me,
what the fuck is going on?
And they were saying,
well,
it's,
it's dependent,
it's time dependent.
It's how much available testosterone to
it.
Like when did they test him?
Was He recovering from sleep?
Was he at its peak?
There was.
Did he had he done explosive athletics
like squats or deadlifts very recently,
and then recovered his testosterone ramp
back up.
Did they catch Weidman after Weidman had
a grueling workout and his testosterone
was down?
Right.
There's a lot of factors apparently
that,
that play into that and Weidman and he
even said himself,
he said,
look,
I,
I kind of have low testosterone while
this.
While TRT was illegal.
He's like,
I could qualify for it.
I can go in and qualify for it.
Yeah,
I remember that very well,
but dev toward did not have any,
uh,
he did not have testosterone.
He did his level was high and all of
that,
but he didn't have any endogenous
testosterone in him.
He had no supplement whatsoever,
so that was a little bit misunderstood.
And then also thank you very much.
And then also to his po or to your point
Weidman,
when he was tested,
if he would have been tested in the
morning,
it would have been down a if he would've
just had a hard workout and chewed up a
lot of the test,
it would have been done.
So that was a little confusing.
[inaudible] hands were clean there and
Chris was misunderstanding what he was
reading and let loose on him.
And Chris had every right to assume that
[inaudible] was still trying to slip
that through.
That was the better part of his career.
But in fairness,
he wasn't.
When Vitorin goes,
hey,
I'm out.
He really,
he,
he was out and they tested the hell out
of Itar.
He's passed them off.
Victoria went straight.
Yeah,
he had to.
And his body really showed it.
Yeah.
Well,
when did he fought Henderson,
the,
uh,
the third Henderson fight in Brazil.
Uh,
he looked like he was gaining is muscle
mass back.
You looked it looked a little bit
better,
but he's just,
he just does not look like trt Vittorio.
Physically.
He's the guy that's had the,
the,
the biggest difference.
And I just,
I feel like if you're going to just say
you have to be off of it,
I think is ridiculous.
I think,
I mean he wanted that title shot and is
really important to him,
but I feel like that medically they had
a responsibility to give the guy a
break,
like to say we're going to give you six
months of,
of restorative therapy and they'll allow
your body to come back into a normal
testosterone range and then reenter into
the drug testing,
you know,
and we'll test you during that time to
make sure that you're not taking
anything else on top of that.
But to not allow the guy any sort of
medicine that can restart his endocrine
system seems very irresponsible when
it's such a primary factor in
performance in.
You're not talking about like fucking
volleyball,
you're talking about head kicks,
you know,
and the difference between getting beat
up and not getting beat up there between
getting brain damage and not getting
brain damage could.
That could play a huge factor in there.
Right?
Yeah.
And I think in hindsight,
I think the commission would have
handled it different.
They've kind of even said that,
hey,
we pulled the rug out here and they went
as close to taking some,
some of the responsibilities you could
without taking it.
And the other side was fighters.
We should've been able to myself,
we should have been,
was just go time,
time out.
I can't comply,
but I want to be in compliance,
but I can't right now.
I've taken my oars out of the water.
I'm going to go do my.
Leave me out of it.
Don't test me.
I'll tell you right now.
It's not.
Give me six months.
To your point,
you'd almost have to retire,
but none of us knew.
None of us.
None of us knew what we didn't know.
Like with Vandelay,
when the guy showed up,
when the guy came to me and I'm in the
closet with none of us knew what was
going on.
It's kind of a different world now.
You have to have that education process.
Whatever John's going through with Tim
means,
what frame this is,
how we learn,
you know,
we learned from guys stumbling and
stubbing their toe.
They just don't give a big allowance for
that.
It's pretty black and white on these
rules.
John's going to be out for two years.
I keep hearing things speculative on how
long it's going to be real clear as it's
going to be off for two years.
That's the minimum.
If he testified he's out for two years.
That's just what it is.
Well,
Anderson wasn't now for two years.
What was the person?
Uh,
Anderson beat the clock on the mandatory
how long you're out.
He came in just before that.
Hector lumbar came in just before that.
So those guys weren't subject to that.
Anderson got,
they could have done whatever they want
for it.
To him,
the standard was nine to 12 months.
He probably would have got nine,
but he denied it to the event,
the hate that he shows up.
All of a sudden he doesn't speak
English.
They hate that they were still pretty
light on him though for three substances
and a guy that still a was resisting the
test and coming in with the store and
refusing to talk to him 12 months that
they were pretty reasonable by their
standards,
by their standard.
What do you think is a reasonable
suspension?
If a guy does get popped for estrogen
blockers and he says,
Hey,
I fucked up.
I want an edge.
I took it.
What's a reasonable amount of
suspension?
What?
My answer will be different because you
said for estrogen blockers,
again,
he's blocking something.
He's not adding something.
He's blocking something.
Now they come back in with their
intellectual approach to go where you're
only blocking it because you did
something before.
We didn't catch it before,
so we're going to get you now.
Not a terrible argument,
but if you just look at what he did,
I think that.
I think there needs to be some
conversation there.
I was there in front of the Commission
One day I got approved for a steroid for
testosterone.
That same day,
Nick Diaz took $100,000 fine and lost
his license for a year for pot of which
he had illegal medication for Blah Blah.
You know the story on that,
so you never know what's going to happen
when you get in there.
You never know what's going to happen.
It's not a courtroom.
Media likes to say he's gonna have his
day in court.
Well that's the.
You don't have a day in court.
Court implies a judge which implies a
disinterested third party.
You're going in front of the people who
have accused you,
so if they clear you there,
now admitting they got it wrong to start
with,
that's literally never happened.
They have never been wrong where they
go,
hey,
we have this wrong.
Go on about your day.
It's never happened.
Is vandelay the first guy to sue the
athletic commission and when.
Okay,
was he the for?
I can't think of anyone else,
but I'd have to look.
You know,
Nick Diaz did the same thing and they
finally said,
okay,
he'll look,
let's settle,
but I think with Nick Diaz,
they made a compromise and they,
they,
they abandoned for five years for pot
and the world went crazy and I gave out
the fucking Nevada state athletic
commission,
his phone number.
I was like,
call him up,
tell him it's sucks.
Sure.
And the whole world went crazy.
Internet was,
they were making petitions and everybody
was emailing and writing people.
People were like justifiably outraged,
but that,
that was a little bit different.
They reduced his sentence and the
vandelay thing was interesting because
it seemed like a judge outside of the
commission made the call.
That is who did it and it was really
weird because they came in with two
things.
First off,
can you banned him for life?
And second,
did you have jurisdiction over?
Now if you read the statute,
you don't have to be a lawyer.
The statute is very small and it's
extremely clear.
They did not have jurisdiction over him.
At the same time,
they can do anything they want so they
could banned him for life.
You get in front of the judge,
the judge rule,
just the opposite.
You can't ban him for life.
That's too extreme,
which is not true for the statute.
They can do that that historically they
have,
but they can.
They did not have the right to test him
though because he was not licensed yet
in Nevada and the statute clearly says
to the licensee of which he was not
kaiser who was in at the time said,
listen,
the fights been announced in my state.
He's in my state.
That gives me the right.
Well,
the judge agreed with him that judge got
it just backwards,
but when they did it,
when they didn't realize,
when the judge did not rule on how long
the suspension would be,
he sent him back to Nevada.
He still hasn't got that result.
So for everyday they kicked the can down
the road.
They when he's still suspended,
so he got his release from the UFC.
He can go fight in another state he
wants right now.
Well,
he's preparing to fight fader,
right?
Isn't that a fight that they were trying
to make for reason?
Not that I know of.
I heard,
I heard a rumor that he would get to
that eventually,
but vandelays got some kind of wrestling
thing lined up for like a tag team.
Wrestling matches how it's going to ease
his way back in the pool.
He just killed it.
Got Hit by a car.
I read this.
These.
Okay.
Fortunately,
yeah.
Well I thought I thought he had shoulder
surgery.
He could have.
Could have.
I heard it hasn't the latest
competition.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well I had heard that he was going to be
fighting.
See if you can find that.
I heard that he was going to be fighting
fate or in,
in Japan and you know,
the doorman seeing his fight with
Maldonado was like,
wow,
how far the mighty have fallen.
He does not look the same at all.
Fatigue's a son of a gun too,
man.
When you get tired it doesn't.
It doesn't matter how good you are.
It doesn't matter what you did before.
If you get tired,
you got problems.
Now the good news for him is Maldonado
got tired too.
Yeah.
Momo has never been a guy that's been
the most conditioned guy in the world,
but he is a guy with fantastic boxing,
very good boxing,
and he caught fade or with a couple of
good shots and had them really badly
hurt.
Yeah.
A lot of people think that fight could
have been stopped.
I mean under a bad judge.
I don't think it should have been
stopped,
but under a bad referee it could have
been or referee.
That was a little too quick to pull the
trigger or if it wasn't in Russia for
one.
Yeah,
there were.
There was definitely some politics there
and I felt bad for Maldonado Maldonado
thought he was going to get a fair shake
and I'm looking at it going,
well,
no,
I'm.
Although it makes sure you get a good
paycheck because you're not getting a
fair shake in Russia.
And then he even filed a complaint after
the fact that petition and he felt too.
It's like Malden,
well maybe you don't know how this works
over there,
but that it's over.
It's over.
I mean unless he flat lined them,
he wasn't winning.
Who would've had to have knocked him out
and I'm sure whatever referee at the
time would be very hesitant to stop that
fight with.
Even with theater,
getting his brains beat.
Sure.
If he thought he could make it to the
bell and the real controversy,
it was that first round that you're
talking about with the ref could have
stopped.
It probably should have.
It wasn't a 10,
eight round and it's like,
look,
if that's not a 10,
eight round that what is in that fight?
Should have been a dry.
It was.
It was one round,
but it was 10,
eight,
two,
two rounds for fader.
A lot of people argue rounds two and
three,
but they're.
They're wrong.
Fader one those rounds.
Maybe they are,
but he want them.
They should have been a drop.
Yeah,
he.
Him Not being in the UFC during his
prime is one of the great tragedies of
MMA.
I really,
really feel that I would have loved to
seen the fate or that fought cro,
cop fight in the UFC and I think he
would have been heavyweight champion.
I really do.
I think he.
The only argument against him being the
greatest of all time,
in my opinion,
is Cain Velasquez and I guess you could
kind of make it for overdue,
but I think for doing that got knocked
out by Steve Bay was a healthy Verdugo.
He just got emotional and crazy and he
charged after Steve Bay and steep based
that fucking good.
Yeah,
he is.
He's really good.
I mean Steve Bay is a bad motherfucker.
It was no doubt about it.
He's a deserving world champion,
but man,
I'm just.
I would've loved to seen primetime cane
versus primetime fatal.
Sure.
I'd love to say to you and I maintained
that Cain is the most intimidating
figure in the heavyweight division that
even though he's jerking the curtain on
Saturday night for the,
for the biggest card ever,
he is the most intimidating guy in the
back.
He's a jerk in the curtain jerk and the
curtain is the guy that starts the show.
You've got to pull the curtain out of
the way to start the show that every
started as he started on Saturday night.
Right.
You got the heavy,
the former heavyweight champion who's
headlining cards and had bills with his
name on the top of.
Now a sudden he's jerking the curtain
because it's UFC 200.
That's what I'm saying.
It was the biggest car there was,
you know,
performance.
He had great performance.
Travis Browne is nobody's fool.
No.
Travis Browne is ranked number four in
the world,
was ranked number three and he should be
one of the.
Travis caught him clean straight right
hand at first round.
One of the few guys to beat Josh Barnett
and Travis is a good heavy weight.
You need to be a basketball player.
You talked about steep a minute ago.
Steve plays a good athlete and we don't
have a ton of them.
You know,
some of the great athletes that are that
size.
They go into some other professions.
You don't usually get them in this one.
Steve Bay's a good looking heavyweight.
He moves well.
He works hard.
He's got the wrestling background,
played baseball.
He's just a good guy,
man.
Yeah.
He really.
What?
What came brings to the table is some
freak cardio and perfect technique.
I mean,
he's just,
he's so unusual in his cardio.
We'll kick incredible,
crazy through two of them receive a try
in that.
So we're good on that.
Javier,
pull them aside.
He goes,
Hey,
can we can start working on Wilcox?
I don't know what it was saying,
but they were good.
There was beautiful.
There was nothing wrong with them.
I mean,
some guy when Weidman through that we'll
kick against rockhold you like blah
blah,
blah.
What the fuck are you doing?
And then he gets taken down.
Chris.
Why?
And it wasn't a good.
We'll kick.
It was goofy.
Yeah.
It just didn't look right,
but when you saw throw,
throw,
you're like,
oh that's perfect.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's how he executes.
Punches,
kicks,
takedowns.
Everything is perfect.
There's no wind up.
Nothing.
Nothing has like extra horsepower behind
it.
Everything's precise.
He's one of my favorite all time guys to
watch because of that.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
And that's your porn on for June.
So for doing beats fader who might be
the.
Great.
So you say you don't know who the
greatest ever was.
It was it,
was it a fader or was it cane?
Verdugo.
Unbeatable for doom.
Doesn't end up in the conversation.
It's one of those does things.
He does.
I think he does,
but you know,
I mean because you got to think the
Prime Verducci who beat feet or the
prime for doom that beat cain could
probably have beaten those guys no
matter where.
It's very possible he could have beaten
those guys no matter what.
So I think he does go into the
conversation.
It's just the history,
that cane hat and the history that fade
or had mean canes,
insane wars and the way broke down
junior dos Santos,
it gets knocked out in the first fight
and then the next two fights just puts
off fucking helacious beating on him.
Right.
I think points,
you know,
the MMA,
math sucks.
Sure.
We,
you just,
it's real hard to say this guy,
be that guy.
So He's number one and that guy beat
this guy.
So.
And when you talk about it,
what are the elements that comes in is
that the guys wins and losses and his
skills.
It's also an intimidation factor right?
What kind of intimidation they have,
what we're doing know,
mix the joker face,
and he's always teasing around so he
gets overlooked,
but I don't think that's fair.
You know,
the same thing's happening to bisping.
Weidman comes out,
he says,
bisping's the most undeserving person of
all time to end up at a title spot,
and I'm going to time timeout and
Christmas a start.
But Chris Timeout.
You become famous
and world champion by beating Anderson
Silva.
Bisping just beat the same guy that you
beat.
Bisbing just beat the same guy that puts
yourself over.
Why does it not put bisbing over?
Now?
He just beats rockhold who beat you.
And but bisping still not over.
Now.
It's kind of a weird thing.
Not only does it put bisping over,
but bisping beat rockhold.
When rockhold was fighting,
he wasn't clowning around.
When when Chris beat Anderson,
he beat him twice.
He beat him once.
When Anderson dropped,
his hands was being silly and he got
cracked and everybody was like,
I can't believe Anderson did that.
It was,
it was a terrible way to lose.
It wasn't just that they were going to
exchange and Chris landed a bomb of a
left hook.
No,
it was anderson was pretending to be
hurt and then he was like faking
wobbling and trying to duck out of the
way of punches like he always does and
Chris cracked him.
Then the second fight,
he breaks his leg and he throws,
throws a Kyc,
checks it and breaks late.
Granted Chris beat the shit out of them
the first round and almost like head.
I'm in bad trouble in that first round.
Controlled them on the ground,
beat him up.
So they go into the second round.
He breaks his leg and the second part.
So those are more freakish.
Sure.
Then what bisping debt,
what bisbing did is just straight up,
he fucking landed a beautiful left hook,
heard them moved in for the kill,
closed the show,
legit champion.
One hundred percent.
No controversy.
I've tried fully agree with that and I
love this next match up.
You know,
you heard it's going to be Dan Henderson
and that doesn't go in the rankings.
I get all of that,
but you know,
I liked the UFC when they make the
matches that people want to see and
that's an interesting match.
If you think,
if you think this is going to just go in
and beat him or you look at dance
record,
you think that bisping doesn't go to bed
at night.
Remember on what that was like?
The teasing,
the highlight reel,
all the people to everybody telling them
about,
you know,
making fun of him flying through the air
when he pounded bisbing just to hit.
It was more conscious.
Yeah,
that's his logo.
Yeah.
I mean this is highlight reel,
knockout.
I stayed at Dan Henderson's house for a
month,
helping them train for [inaudible] and
when you turn dance tv off at night,
the remote control says lights out and
it's him hitting bisping lights up.
That's what lights up on his remote
control.
So I mean he doesn't have confidence
going into the shittiest competence.
He knows he could beat him.
He already did.
If you think bespeaks not going,
man,
I really don't want to be in there with
that guy again.
He's going to say,
I want that one back and one,
he's going to say all those things and
try to convince himself,
but the bottom line is that's relevant.
Dan Henderson will be the world
champion.
It's very possible,
very possible.
Look.
He just knocked Hector Lombard dead.
Hector's tougher and health tech.
There's never been given the credit that
he deserved a monster.
Monster fights it two different ways.
Yeah,
Nicholas Power and he had Dan hirt and
Dan had hit her.
He,
Dan hurt him first.
Hector came back,
hurt Dan.
Dan recovered and knocked him out with a
crazy fucking elbow and then another
shot when once he moves basically out
from that back elbow,
but it shows that Dan can still shut the
lights out on a guy in his prime who's a
destroyer,
who's never been knocked out before in
the aunt.
I fully agree.
Disagree.
There's one of those guys of what
happens
to them and hector stubbed his toe a few
times.
You want to see hector fight.
Hector's got the whole thing.
He's going to do the promos before and
he's going to mean it.
He's going to hate that opponent.
It's real,
he's going to look like a million bucks
and he's going to come out fight and
whatever happens after that happens,
but he's coming to fight when he went
out on his shield.
Um,
and when you look at this fight between
bisping and Henderson,
that's the most exciting fight.
I mean,
that's why I liked the fact that the UFC
made it.
That's the fight that I wanted to see.
I put it on my instagram.
I'm like,
come,
yes,
please,
let's make it happen.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
That's the fight.
And if Dan goes out,
Dan came to my,
uh,
I,
his fight was on a Saturday.
He came to my show at the Ice House in
Pasadena on Wednesday.
He said he had been drunk since
Saturday.
That sounds great.
He was so happy.
And I'm like,
well,
what do you think?
Is it possible?
And like,
we're trying,
we're trying to make that happen.
Like the bisping fight.
I'm like,
that is the fight to make.
And I go,
would you retire if,
if that would,
if you went out with that,
fine.
He goes,
yeah,
he goes as the only fight I want right
now.
It goes,
I don't even really want to fight
anybody else.
I want to fight him,
and then I think I'm done now.
What about what George St Pierre was
saying he would come back and he wanted
bisping and if George comes to the table
and says,
I'll come back,
but only if.
Well then it's only if you're doing it,
you're doing that.
That's a big fight.
If he comes back and fights bisping.
I don't know if it's a bigger fight than
Henderson.
I agree that it doesn't sell more,
but I'm saying if that's what you gotta
do to get George back to the table,
I think.
I think you do it.
Don't if you're Dana,
don't you do.
Okay.
You don't think that's what you need to
do.
I think he's just saying that because
it's an attractive option because you
know bisping has the title.
It's an interesting fight.
He wouldn't have to cut weight.
Mean literally.
He's walking around at one 86.
This is a much larger.
Got Larger.
You think that Dana told George?
No,
no,
I don't want to do that match.
No,
I just think they probably didn't.
Didn't really have it worked out.
They were probably discussing it and
trying to figure out what the details
would be,
but if you look at the most attractive
fight to Bisping,
I would think the Henderson fight would
be because Dan doesn't have much time
left.
If he misses them this time around,
he might not ever be able to fight them
again.
This being legitimately wants to get
revenge and he's the world champion now.
It's his call,
so Kudos to him for taking this fight
for saying,
you know what man,
this guy just blew.
It's not like.
It's not like he called them out right
after.
He just got knocked out in the first
round by [inaudible] know you called
them out after you just destroyed Hector
Lombard and like that was one of the
greatest knockouts in the history of the
sport.
I mean when that happened,
because when you consider all that was
at stake when you consider that Dan was
45 years old,
that people thought he was in the
twilight of his career.
That he's stepping in there to fight
hector.
Lumbar was just a fucking monster in his
prime.
Like that was a great knockout.
An all time great result.
So Kudos to bisping.
Kudos to bisping for wanting that fight
now and the way bisping needs to handle
it.
When you factor Shaka Ryan,
who's going,
hey,
wait a minute,
I have beaten you.
I got the skills to beat you on the
number one contender.
Here's how bisping we'll handle it.
No,
you're not.
Wait your.
That's how they'll handle
the way to shut those guys down.
Joe.
It's to go back to the truth,
the truth,
your friend.
Listen,
Jacques Rey,
you're more dangerous.
You're more likely to beat me and I'm
not looking to get beat,
so I'm going to go deal with this guy.
It shuts everything.
A bisbing won't do it.
Everybody likes to go,
well wait your turn and this and then
you're not as good as you think you are.
Go fight your over America.
Whatever it is,
steer right into it.
Yeah man,
you're way more like,
here's what I want to do.
I want to fight the easiest guy in the
biggest stadium for the largest paycheck
and that's what I'm going to politic to
do.
So you do your thing and I'm going to do
mine.
Well,
the Socceroos,
is that right?
Okay.
Not very good for JOC ray,
because he lost the fight with your
Ramiro.
I for some reason.
Erroneous.
Yeah.
I had an erroneous memory of jock or a
winning the decision.
I don't know why.
Maybe it's because of him testing
positive,
but it was a very close fight too.
I remember not knowing after it was
over.
I mean I remember you well blasted them
and had them really badly hurt,
but I felt like Zachary came back a bit
and it was a very close fight towards
the end,
but it's very tough.
I agree with the decision popped,
but I can see it.
It was tight.
Jacques raised.
He's fantastic.
They're both fantastic.
Yeah,
they really are.
And when he.
When he lost that fight though,
it's real hard to lose a fight.
Even if a guy that popped for a tainted
supplement that mean they only give them
a six month suspension,
it's real hard to make an argument that
you deserve the next shot at the title.
I think that actually solidifies dance
position.
Sure.
I agree with you.
Can I switch gears?
Yeah.
I got to ask you about.
You asked me about anything.
Joey Diaz.
Tell me everything.
How did you meet Joe des [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Then I want you to ask me this.
I want you to ask me what my experience
with joy,
but how did you meet him?
How did he come into the fold?
I met Joey Diaz in the late nineties,
uh,
at the comedy store.
I think I met him in like [inaudible] 96
or 97,
something like that.
Uh,
right when Joey moved to La,
we just started hanging around the
comedy store.
We became friends and then I started
taking on the road with me.
Like,
uh,
the late nineties.
We've been best friends forever,
so I know of Joey.
I don't know Joey.
I've never met him.
Never met Joe.
Whenever I call him up right now,
TV and the whole bit and you know,
I know him from,
from you and I see your podcast and all
that,
but.
And he's in the circles.
He does some Jujitsu,
he's funnier than hell and he's a
gangster.
So I like him,
but I don't know anything about him.
So he comes on my podcast now he has a
podcast,
so of course my opening line to them as,
hey,
how'd you get into pocket?
Right?
I'm going to put here,
here's your plug for your podcast and
we're going to go on and talk about my
agenda.
So I say,
Joe,
I say to him,
Joey,
how'd you get into podcasting?
And his response,
you know Chael Sonnen,
he wouldn't call me jail.
It was always.
She calls me Joe Rogan.
I'm mugged a hooker down in New Jersey
and senator Lee said her wig on fire.
It's okay.
We got to.
There's two moving parts here.
First off,
that is,
I don't know how that answers my
question of how,
but now I need to know the story here.
So we ties it all together with.
He went on something,
just something,
he got an appearance.
He told the story of mugging her a
hooker in New Jersey and setting her wig
on fire and all of a sudden he blew up
overnight and he goes,
yeah.
I realized people like the stores.
I never knew that I had stories from the
part of the country.
I'm in the neighborhood I grew up in.
I thought everybody had these doors.
He's like,
chill son.
And I thought I'd tell you I mogul
hooker and lighter wig on fire.
You Go,
yeah,
well I'm up 10 hookers and let 10 wigs
on fire.
I was like,
I didn't know I had stories and then it
just goes from there.
And he starts telling me about.
So He.
So he,
he ends up doing two years or 18 months
and I said,
well,
what kind of jam did you get in there?
And he said,
well,
I was actually,
I was doing the cop's job for them.
You know,
the cops don't want drugs on the
streets.
I went,
took two kilos off the streets form.
This is how he presents it to me.
He goes,
yeah,
you know,
the,
the two kilos wasn't as big of a deal.
Oh.
He said,
Oh,
I,
I robbed two kilos.
He goes,
and you know what else?
Chael Sonnen,
I just happened to have a machine gun
and I go,
I can see where that happened because
she is sometimes you just back into a
machine gun.
I had a machine gun with me and he goes,
but it's funny.
I wasn't in trouble for the gun.
I really wasn't that much trouble for
the drugs.
What they were upset about was the
kidnapping.
I'm going,
okay,
what,
what happened here?
This is my intro to the guy.
I'm like,
what?
What in the hell is this story?
You probably know the story,
but I did it.
So he tells me the whole story.
He says,
yeah,
but you know,
kidnappings,
kind of a weird charge.
He goes,
when you and vandelay gotten that
scuffle in the ultimate fighter,
if I come and grab you and take you into
the next room just to cool you down,
taking you into a room against your
will,
that's kidnapping.
So I think like they got him on a
technicality jam,
like what they're doing with Frank Mir.
Some of these guys were talking about
and I said,
okay,
is that what happened?
And he goes,
no,
I duct taped the game.
He's in my trunk.
And then I held him in the house for a
week before I let him go.
Well then why didn't you tell me?
Why did you bring up the initial example
of taking me next door and cooling me
debt?
What that have to do?
I still don't know because he's crazy.
It's funnier than hell.
And I asked.
So I was trying to talk like some.
See I try to do more of a Joe Rogan
experience.
You're,
you're my idol.
I try to do my show the way you do
yours,
but I'm not there yet.
It takes a while to build that audience.
So I got a stick on MMA and pro
wrestling.
I got to really stay in,
but I don't want that.
I want just.
I want to just talk.
You could just talk.
You.
You definitely could just talk was I
bring these guys in.
I'm trying to do a little more that I go
to Tmz,
I see the local stuff,
I try to ask them pop culture questions.
So I dip my toe in politics with Joey
Obama had just made this new rule of
going to the bathroom you want.
So I asked Joey about that and he goes,
chill son.
And I've been taking a dump in the
woman's bathroom since I'm five years
old and believe me,
I have dealt with the consequences,
but he wasn't kidding Joe.
That's what's made this.
It's a shoot.
He's being real.
And he tells me he is pro wrestling.
He goes,
well,
my mom used to own a restaurant so you
know,
I kinda had.
I cleaned the bag and then I sit down in
the women's.
He goes,
you know what happens if you drop,
you drop your coke on a men's bathroom
floor.
No,
I don't know.
I don't do like,
I've tested positive for everything in
the world,
but coke was at one of them.
I used.
Since you leave it there,
you know what happens if I drop my
coconut,
a women's bathroom floor,
you'd get down and lick it up.
That's what he.
He says,
everybody's trying to say the women's
rooms cleaning he'd been used up,
says he's five years old and he said,
and I have dealt with the consequences,
which I knew I want the answer to what
those were.
It's just,
it's like there's too many other things
to talk to this guy,
but I got to get back to the hooker with
the wig that he mugged.
I've known Joe.
He was busy
20 years and he's never stopped running
out of stories and they're all real
people.
His wife is so fucking crazy that people
go,
oh,
that guy just comes on your show and
make stuff up.
That's what people used to say when I
used to have them on these to say like
when we first started doing the podcasts
that I'm tired of that Joey Diaz Guy.
He's lying.
He's just making things up.
Haters would say that,
but then people would come on his show
and substantiate.
He would call people up in New Jersey
that he grew up with.
They would tell.
He would go,
Tom,
that fucking story about the time we lit
the whole [inaudible] word on fire and
then they would tell the same story like
he's lived a movie,
not a movie,
like an epic adventure series of novels.
I kids life is insane.
Well,
to qualify.
So he tells this story about Robin,
this guy with a machine gun that he just
happened to have taken the two kilos off
the street during the cop's job for him,
but then having the guy in his trunk
duct tape before I moved into the house
before I let him go.
He had that guy on his podcast.
Yes.
He found him on social media,
tried to friend him or like him or
whatever you call it,
on faith.
I'm a twitter guy,
but this was facebook guy ignored him
for about two years.
Finally responded.
Now Joey's had them on his pockets.
He says,
we catch up about once a month and he
goes,
yeah,
and the guy was good people.
He never turned me in.
He said it was yet,
it was my partner in the whole thing.
The partner try to double cross me and
we stole the coke.
Then he was going to steal it from me,
but I knew what time it was.
That's an expression I'd never heard
before,
but I plan to take with me through my
next years in life,
whenever.
Wherever you go.
I knew what time it was.
I just thought that was a great line.
The whole thing was I asked him about
the gorilla.
The gorilla had just got shot where they
killed him at the zoo and he says,
you know what?
Chill Center.
They don't give us the good gorillas.
I'm.
I'm down at the zoo last week,
the gorillas,
they got their hair messed up.
They don't eat bananas.
They want chicken cutlets.
Shoot the FN gorilla.
It's like you had no idea was going to
ask you that.
That was so spontaneously funny.
You know that news had just broken,
right?
Then I was like,
this is the guy.
This is a funny guy.
No,
he's unbelievable.
He's the funniest person I've ever met
in my life.
He's the funniest comedian I've ever
seen in my life.
Well,
I've seen them live or you got to see
him live with.
How long have you.
I'm here until tomorrow.
I'm gonna do fighter and the kid I got
to see.
Speaking of Qa,
I got to see Adam Hunter last night live
and he lit it up.
Adam Hunter was very funny.
He was very funny.
He's very good.
He's really good writer.
He worked the whole crowd in he.
He made it a thing.
Any any sold the venue out is his real
intimate atmosphere at stratos for I
would guess 100 seats.
A very small,
but it was packed.
That's perfect.
Went right around the room.
I mean he rose.
There's nothing off limits.
Women's jokes,
gay jokes,
racial jokes,
everything,
and it was awesome and possibly as
funny.
It's like who's going around to couple.
Hey,
how'd you guys meet?
You know,
where'd you guys meet Jimmy at the UFC?
You guys fight phase during the whole
thing there.
A nerdy coupling.
[inaudible].
Where'd you guys meet?
Lenscrafters.
It's right.
See,
brilliance is in it's simplicity.
You can use that line in school and not
even get a detention.
I mean,
that's a,
that's a powerful and funny line.
And the teacher can even send you to the
office for me.
Right?
It's not me,
it's just bloody now.
He's a funny dude.
He's,
he's,
I got in trouble for quoting one of his
jokes during a fox broadcast,
like a Fox sports one.
Who was the fighter that he was telling
a joke about?
Um,
he said he comes from behind more than
Lance Bass.
Yes.
Who Was it?
Can't remember.
But that was a funny line.
Yes.
You use like a paper view though,
or.
I think it was,
it was on fs one that was part of the
problem.
Okay.
It works.
Martin Kampmann.
Yeah,
it was Martin Cameron and uh,
I just wanted to credit him because it
made me laugh so hard.
That's why I said as my friend Adam
Hunter,
so I kind of got away with it because it
wasn't.
My joke is if I had said it,
sure.
Well here,
if we're playing,
if we're playing that game,
I can't tell one,
but if I quote him,
maybe I can't.
He sends me a text after the Orlando
shooting the very next day.
He says,
Hey man,
let me know you're okay.
I heard there was a shooting at a gay
club.
I just want to check on you.
It's like,
now you got to do that in private.
You
can do anything.
They want this loophole.
It's hilarious.
I'm just reading that shit.
That's funny.
I wonder how many other people you said
that too,
but the right mark for that because
that's funny.
That's funny.
It is funny.
Well,
that's a weird position.
I believe in the rule,
Joe.
If it's funny then you can do it.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well both.
Funny.
Subjective,
right?
Like what's funded you?
Other people might get offended and
that's one of the things that people who
love to be recreationally outrage.
That's what they do.
They'll find a joke and they'll say,
that's not funny to me.
It's horribly offensive and it's
degrading and blah blah,
and they'll come up with a bunch of
reasons why.
It shouldn't be funny,
but if there's someone out there that's
howling at the same time,
you're protesting the other person's
howling laughing,
then it did its job for you,
for me.
You sent out a great tweet.
You might.
It might've been as recently as
yesterday,
but the for it was a two part.
The first part said this country does.
This country has a mental health problem
disguised as a gun problem and this
country has a tyranny problem disguised
as a security problem.
It's a security problem and it went
crazy.
Twitter lit up and when I'm reading that
I'm going,
okay,
Joe's dip it in something here.
Joe Doesn't usually dip in,
but he's right.
There was no way to say that that
statement is not right and it wasn't
meant to be funny.
That was a very true and I thought a
powerful statement by you.
Thank you.
It's actually a couple of years old.
It's just a,
it's just going around a lot.
People who are retweeting it.
Okay.
Came back,
but it's um,
there's no way you can't call what
happened in Orlando,
a mental health problem.
There's plenty of guns.
There are more guns than there are human
beings in this country,
and if there was a gun problem,
the way a lot of people like to pretend
there's a gun problem or the way they
like to,
I shouldn't say pretend because
obviously there's an issue.
Um,
the way they like to categorize it.
There would be people shooting people in
mass all day long.
Every day.
It would be impossible to go out of the
house without looking for gunfire.
That's not the case.
Will you think about how many people are
there are and how many guns there are in
how statistically rare it is that these
things happen.
It,
it shows you,
and then you factor in how many of these
people are on anti depressants,
how many of these people are being
weened off of antidepressants?
Those numbers are terrified because when
you look at the correlation and the
correlation does not equal causation is
there's a weird argument,
but it's an undeniable factor that has
to be at least debated and discussed.
There are so many fucking people in this
country on disassociating meds on things
that allow you to get away with you.
You could justify and do and act in
horrific ways and not exactly know what
the fuck you're doing.
That is one of the problems that's
associated with certain antidepressants
and too dumb to not connect those two is
crazy and to not,
and even if they're not medicated,
forget about the medication because the
medication is one issue with the type of
person that can go into a fucking school
and shoot a bunch of kids.
If you don't think that's a mental
illness issue,
oh,
it's only a gun issue.
That's fucking crazy.
It's not a gun issue.
That's like calling nine slash 11 a
plane issue.
Right?
It's not.
It's not a gun issue.
The gun factor is real.
There is a problem if psycho people and
people with criminal records are people
that are mentally disturbed,
combined guns,
yes.
That's a problem.
You know,
what else is the problem?
The fact that I can get a fucking,
I can get a gun and I don't even know
how to use it.
That's a problem.
Sure.
You have to have a license to drive a
car.
If someone has to sit with you that you
have to take these turns,
you have to turn right here,
you have to fully stop at the stop sign.
You have to do all these things.
And if you don't do it,
don't.
You don't get your driver's license.
Oh,
you have to do is not be a criminal and
you'd get a gun.
Right?
That is fucking crazy.
And at any age two.
And that's relevant.
Uh,
my nephew is eight years old.
When he got last Christmas,
he got a gun and we live in the country.
That's normal.
Kids have guns by the time they're eight
years old at three,
four years old.
They're starting with bb guns.
They advanced to appellate.
You've got a shotgun.
Some parts of the world go,
man.
That's insane.
You gave a kid a gun.
Well,
where we live out in the car.
Yes.
The kid has the gun at the other side of
it though,
there is no crimes where I come from,
done with a gun,
whether a guy's doing a simple robbery
and I don't mean to dismiss that,
but in the in the eyes of murder,
it is never and one of the reasons that
we maintain is when you have guns and
you grow up with guns,
you learn the dangers of guns.
You never play with those things.
You never point those things at anybody.
When you're out shooting watermelons and
pop cans or whatever it may be.
You learn real fast.
This is why I don't pull a gun.
This is why I don't do this because we
don't.
We don't know anything about the things
like the cities in New York and all
these people that are trying to take the
guns away.
We don't know anything about that out in
the country.
Never.
We don't have any gun problems and
everybody's got them.
Well,
don't you also think that living in a
place like the country where everybody
does have guns,
that is very different environment than
living in a city.
If everybody had guns in the city,
you have so much more tension going on.
It's so much.
It's so much different.
Like the environment's different like
that.
I don't necessarily think it would be
great if New York City had as many guns
per capita as Oregon.
Sure,
sure.
In your original point on this is the
only thing that stops you from getting a
gun is having a felony is like,
well that makes sense and nobody's
disputing that,
but there's got to be a few more things.
To your point,
we need to find out if you're medicaid
as simple drug tests.
This is pretty quick.
You know,
the NRA is real big that a guy gets a
gun today because he might need to say,
well no,
the guy's got to plan ahead.
It's just like a driver's license.
Maybe.
Maybe the 16 year old has a date on
Saturday,
but if he doesn't have the license and
he's going to have to postpone the date
because there needs to be more things
than just simply going,
you know,
let,
let me run your fingerprints and if
something comes back to your point,
are you on drugs and medication?
How about a train of thought?
I've never heard anybody make that
argument before,
but I love that analogy.
You have to get a license for a car.
It's pretty simple process but you have
to do it.
Why you shifted it with a gun too
because people need to know why you
don't use guns 100 percent.
I mean you have to get a hunter safety,
a certificate if you want to hunt and if
you want to use the gun and you know
it's really,
it's very detailed in most states.
You have to have one in many states at
least.
Actually,
I don't even think you have to have in
California,
but you,
which is weird because California is
like one of the most restrictive states
when it comes to firearms,
but you,
you have to go through this long
difficult course and you have to pass
tests and you have to actually know what
the fuck you're doing and if you don't
you don't get your hunter safety
certificate and then you can't.
You can't hunt,
can't get a license,
right?
Yeah.
You can't get a license and I think that
what the NRA does is they take a hard
stance on the side of promoting guns and
they don't move.
Not only do they not budge,
they almost are unreasonable in their
position,
but I feel like that is because the left
is so unreasonable when anything goes
on,
they immediately want to ban guns and
take guns away that it's not.
It's not feasible at this day and people
are like,
well,
we're going to do that.
Australia,
Australia is 20 million people.
It's the size of the continental United
States.
To Equate Australia with the United
States is insane.
There's just way too many people here.
It's a completely different and by the
way,
they didn't ban guns in Australia.
People hunt with guns.
You can get guns,
you can register guns.
You get them.
You'd go to.
You'd be belong part of hunting clubs
like they do in Europe.
You keep them stored in lockers.
It's not a full on band.
On firearms is just much more
restrictive.
The NRA is trying to stop restrictions
and the reason why they're trying to
stop restrictions because you know when
anything goes on television,
it's very disingenuous for someone to go
on television after some sort of a
massacre and not bring up all the
factors,
not bring up psych meds,
not bring up mental health,
not talk about the correlation between
raising kids in abusive households and
having children grow up with this,
these horrible lives,
and then they go on and become fucking
psychopaths.
Sure,
there's a correlation there.
It's not simply whether or not the kid
had the tool to do the job.
It's like,
why the fuck did they want to do that in
the first place?
And then you find out so many of these
cases,
like this guy in Orlando,
the FBI had them on a watch list just a
couple of years ago twice.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on man,
that,
that fucking kid in Colorado that killed
everybody at the movie theater.
They knew that guy was out of his
fucking mind.
He had talked about killing a bunch of
people and there's a lot of those cases
where they get ignored and that's a
giant issue and I don't know how to
solve that issue because what do you do
when someone comes along and says,
Hey,
I'm thinking about going into a movie
theater and killing a bunch of people.
I'm just kidding.
You know,
like what do you,
what do you,
do?
You know how I'm going to go buy your
first statement and lock you up forever?
You know,
I don't know.
I don't know what to do there.
And I,
I think there's a gigantic argument when
it comes to gun violence in this
contract,
but there's a gigantic argument when it
comes to mental illness and we're
pushing that one aside.
Yeah.
And I think they just do it at the wrong
time,
you know,
they get emotions involved.
Jfk made a statement,
uh,
back when he was president,
never let a good crisis go to waste.
So it is believed by politicians.
When you have a crisis,
that's when you go on the attack.
But that's when the emotions are the
highest.
I disagree with this statement.
It's a good time to get your agenda out
there,
but you're just pissing people off and
you're entrenched in them in their own
views.
A great time to bring up the gun
argument.
I'm pro gun,
but I do understand.
Look,
there's some room to give her.
I love what you said about a licensed.
You relate that to a driving a car.
It makes perfect sense.
Bring it when emotions are a little bit
less comfortable and go,
hey,
listen,
let's make sure we do this.
And if you're worried about your safety,
kind of get a little bit proactive here.
Start the process that you can have a
gun if that's what you want to do.
But I don't agree.
I think that they're,
they're,
they're wrong.
Following Jeff K's model that he said in
1964,
I think here in 2016,
let emotions die down a little bit,
let not people not be pissed on one side
or the other.
Worried about protecting themselves and
their family were worried that
something's going to happen to
themselves with their family.
You get good people with really
different views here.
I think that they're misplacing jfk
philosophy in my opinion.
In 2016,
let things die down a little bit and
then bring it up.
Yeah,
and there's also this weird adherence,
concrete adherence to the bill of rights
and you know the second amendment.
I mean,
yeah,
I think that people should look.
I don't think if there's only three of
us in this world.
All right,
you,
me and Jamie were the only ones.
If Jamie came along and said nobody
could have guns,
I think we would get together and go,
fuck that guy.
Who's this guy to tell us what we can
and can't do.
That same thought process could be
applied to 300 million people.
It just.
I don't agree that a grown human being
should be able to tell another grown
human being what they can and can't do
as long as it's not like if you say,
hey joe,
I'm thinking about starting a fucking
nuclear power plant in your backyard and
I'm pretty sure it know what I'm doing,
but if we're going to have to move to
the middle of the ocean,
right,
well then we got a problem and you could
sort of apply that logic to guns.
You say,
well,
you know,
if you,
if you're a fucking gun nut and you'd
like to shoot guns off in your backyard
and you know,
you might ricochet one and fucking shoot
my dog or something,
then it becomes a safety issue and a
health issue.
But it's hard to justify using the words
of people that lived in the fucking 17
hundreds when it comes to today with the
kind of guns that we have with the kind
of society that we have with the kind of
just our,
our,
our across the board,
our legal system,
our,
our system of government,
representative,
government,
all that stuff is fucking bananas in the
world of 2016.
Representative government has no place
in a world where everyone has social
media where everyone can be represented
instantaneously.
You don't have to get on a fucking horse
and take a parchment across the country
to hand it to some dude in a powdered
wig that's old that we don't need that
anymore.
So when you start talking about things
that are in the bill of rights and
things that are in the constitution,
ge think it's time to update that
fucking ancient piece of shit.
I mean it's,
it was great.
They had amazing insight.
They were brilliant people.
We owe them everything.
This experiment of self government,
the United States of America was founded
on,
is a fantastic invention and it's one of
the reasons why so much art and
creativity and innovation and freedom
come from this part of the world,
but to rely on the exact words written
with a fucking feather back when people
were taken wooden boats across the
ocean,
hoping they wouldn't get eaten by
Indians when they land in here.
I mean the native Americans.
Sorry.
Um,
it's,
I just think it's ridiculous to say
anything we're not supposed to know.
So it was right up there with retard.
And could you say homo?
I think he's still,
say Homo.
Homo sapiens.
I did not know that.
Politicians try to be correct all the
time and say African American.
But that term is wrong.
It's black.
Yes.
Not all.
Not all blacks are Africans.
A lot of people from Haiti.
Yeah.
To your point that people have this
absolute fetish for the constitution.
No matter how many times we've amended
over the years and it extends to the
bill of a bill of rights to it and they
need to take,
you know,
you bring up a feather,
but,
and that's accurate.
They sign it with a feather,
but they were also married to their
cousin and they bathed once a week and
they had slaves.
There you go.
And it's like,
hey guys,
things changed.
So these guys did their level best at
that time,
but they couldn't see the world and it,
you know,
in perpetuity.
And then assign it is no matter how many
times we've amended the constitution,
you guys still have a fetish that this
was like the Gospel.
This wasn't touched by the hand of God.
This was written by knuckleheads with
eighth grade educations.
Yeah.
And just do what?
And the thing about the bill of rights,
the reason why they cling to that second
amendment is because it does state that
you have the right to bear arms.
So they got it.
It's written down.
It's all right.
Sure we got it.
And people also love the basis behind
it.
It wasn't about hunter and gatherer like
some people say it was about,
look,
if our government has guns,
then we have guns so that we can always
overtake our government should we need
to now in the world of tanks and
aircraft and everything.
Of course that doesn't.
That doesn't hold,
but that's the part that people like.
They don't want to give their government
the power of the people don't have.
That is a wonderful philosophy,
but it's.
It's kind of outgrown itself.
It has
ron itself in the United States of
America in 2016,
but if the shit hits the fan and it
absolutely could.
We are one natural disaster away from
chaos at all times and that is something
that has happened all throughout human
history.
There have been gigantic asteroidal
impacts.
There have been super volcanoes.
There have been tidal waves.
There's been a lot of shit that happens.
Then all of a sudden,
chaos mean we saw what happened with
Katrina.
Katrina hit and there was looting and
rioting and chaos and people have the
right to defend themselves and protect
themselves in that kind of situation.
When people go crazy,
then you factor in the possibility of
government going crazy.
That is just as much of a possibility.
It's happened all throughout history.
It's happening in Russia right now.
Sure.
Russia is being run by fucking gangsters
and not the sun and Kai.
Sure.
A different kind of gangs.
Right?
I mean,
Putin is a murderer.
He's a tyrant for sure.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm not an effective leader for,
for all the wrong word,
but yeah,
he is effective.
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
I just,
uh,
I think there is an argument that when
people have ultimate power,
they also have massive potential for
corruption.
We see that today with the Clinton
campaign,
this,
this nonsense with the fucking emails
and they'll classify data that she had
inadvertently or purposely sent through
email and then the difference between
her take on it and what the FBI's take
on it was like this clearly lying going
on.
There's clearly corruption going on
because clearly people protecting her
and that kind of corruption where it
wouldn't apply to you and it wouldn't
apply to me.
We would go to jail.
Sure.
If we,
if we sent those same emails,
if we were involved in the transfer of
top secret information through erroneous
fucking pathways or however the fuck she
did it,
and I'm not,
I don't exactly know the specifics,
but if we did any of those things,
we would most likely be convicted and we
would most likely at least get find a
massive amount of money,
but more likely.
Sure.
Martha,
Martha Stewart went to jail just for
lying to the FBI.
You know,
now is in that same jam.
The FBI saying they didn't look into it.
That whole thing is very for gazy.
Yeah,
no,
that whole thing is very corrupt and I
think that call me at the FBI's a
reasonable guy or are however,
I tend to believe him,
but that was never a fair shake.
Obama stays out of the whole thing.
Then he finally comes in a law lynch.
Loretta Lynch finally comes in and says,
well,
we're going to honor whatever the FBI
says,
and then four days later the FBI drops
the news.
It's like,
guys,
this is.
Forget this has been going on for a
year.
You know,
I'll tell you something else you know
who looks weak in the whole thing is the
FBI.
These guys are supposed to be great.
We put 40 people on the Hillary Clinton
place to put that in perspective for the
listeners,
for people were assigned to Al Capone 10
times the amount and it took them one
year of having the evidence to make a
ruling.
I mean,
come on,
that's weak and the same thing's going
on with Isis.
We're supposed to have this great
military and no offense to the people
that serve,
but offense to the people that are
handcuffing our.
Our military isis,
when I first
had heard about them for the very first
time was 200 members strong.
Now they are 4,000 strong and weak.
Still can't stop these guys and we're
supposed to be the best.
Look.
Of course we could.
We just don't,
but it makes us look weak.
That would not happen in Russia.
Nobody attacks the Russians.
If you attack poot and you will be
fighting Putin right now,
no permission,
no congress,
no bs.
You want to go,
you're going to go with Russia,
and that's why nobody
does.
I think you're right.
I think you're definitely right,
and when there's direct evidence of
Clinton's statements versus the FBI
statements,
Clinton saying,
I only used one device.
FBI saying choose multiple devices.
No Clinton saying that no classified or
top secret documents were shared or
leaked.
FBI saying hundreds,
hundreds,
hundreds and deleted.
Yeah,
it's all fucked.
It's all fucked,
but that's corruption and that he
thinks,
and this is not the kind of corruption
that we need to be absolutely terrified
of like they're going to come and steal
our children and take all our money away
and and fucking shoot anybody who talks
back,
that's not that level of corruption,
but it's a slippery slope with any
corruption.
If the laws don't apply to you because
your name is Hillary Clinton,
but the law applies to Chilson under Joe
Rogan.
That's nonsense.
That's not,
that's not the world that we want.
That's the real problem.
When someone is outside of the law or
the law respects them in a different way
that it respects you,
that's not good,
and that's why the second amendment
exists is second amendment exists to
stop fuckery because people are crazy
and when people say,
Whoa,
it's about muskets and it's not.
It's not.
It's for a militia.
It's only the guns or no,
no,
no.
It's to prevent this kind of shit from
getting completely out of hand.
It's prevent the government from taking
over and allow people to form a
resistance.
Sure.
To be honest.
Yeah.
Hey.
So many people think that trump's crazy
and he's going to lead us into warrants
like guys sometime read the art of war.
Just read the art of work is the best
general never fires a shot.
Ever poot and hasn't had a whip.
A lot of vast.
No poodle kill you if he needs to,
but he hasn't had.
He took over a part of the Ukraine,
didn't kill a person.
He rolled in.
He said he wanted it and now he has a
part of the Ukraine k,
that's leadership.
He aligned,
but it's late.
I'm not saying this is good,
but that's what a leader does.
A leader makes a decision.
He goes in and takes her and he didn't
have to kill anybody.
The best general never fires a shot.
Donald trump isn't planning to go and
with people he's planning to make people
think he will whip them,
which is why he's not going to get us
into wars and people.
A lot of people don't see that and trump
can't come out and reveal this big
curtain.
Or people go,
oh well the whole thing's a joke.
He can't do that.
So he's got to stand this ground,
take people saying he's crazy.
Hope that enough.
Uh,
enough people get it to vote them into
office,
but that's all he's doing.
He's going around saying it's our way or
the highway where the economic power
will the military power.
We do things right and you're gonna do
it our way and we're not going to do a
lot of compromising.
When you align like that,
you look at North Korea,
all the craziest they do there.
They scare everybody.
For years we've paid a bunch of money.
Bill Clinton paid them 8 billion.
George Bush paid them six and a half
billion.
I mean,
it doesn't matter
if you're Democrat or Republican,
you're paying these knuckleheads for
making straight.
They've never fired a shot.
They just understand the art of war.
Talked to whoever talks stuff is the
toughest on the playground.
Everybody listening to this had a tough
guy in school.
Hey,
what was the toughest guy in school?
Everybody listening to this right now
can go on.
Take that guy.
They all know.
I'd ask them a follow up question.
Did you ever see him getting a fight?
And all of them are going,
no,
no.
Who'd fight him?
He was the toughest guy in school.
Whoever talks the toughest is the
toughest,
and those rules don't change from the
playground to the octagon,
to the White House.
They don't change the best.
General never fires a shot.
When I was in high school,
the toughest kid beat the fuck out of
everybody.
My name is frank piece.
He was fucking huge.
It's most likely on steroids.
He was a gigantic fuck.
He was so terrified.
My sister dated him for awhile.
He used to imagine how have your sister
date the toughest guy in the school?
Oh,
he was a gorilla.
He used to be able to remember those
universal machines and where they had
the stack,
what was the stack like?
Two 50 or something like that.
He could bench the whole stack like
several times and everybody was like,
whoa.
He does the stack.
He does that.
He had giant stretch marks all over his
tits and he was like 17 with these
things.
It is most likely a steroids.
Pretty sure.
Well,
I ran into a many,
many years later.
He's a great guy by the way.
And um,
he was quite a bit smaller when I ran
into him many years later.
Like,
Oh,
where's the
rest of you?
But you know,
that was back when people really didn't
even understand steroids.
It wasn't a,
there wasn't a lot of people on them,
but my point being toughest kid in my
school beat the fuck out.
Everybody went to a college party and
beat the fuck out of a bunch of guys.
That'll do it.
Yeah.
He knocked down the nation.
That'll carry over.
He was a brick shit house that kid,
but yeah,
but I understand what you're saying.
Sure.
This Donald Trump thing,
which which is interesting to me,
is that what he's done is he's gotten
the media to work for him because he
found a weakness in what they do.
Would they like to do is I'd like to
talk shit with the media likes to do is
they look to find something that they
feel like is going to be embarrassing or
something that they can focus on and
really drone on and on about it,
but with him he owns it and it's similar
to what you were talking about with
promoting yourself and promoting
yourself as a fighter.
He's promoting himself in a lot of the
ways the same way.
Kind of the you would do.
I mean,
what he's doing is he's not apologizing.
He's saying provocative things and
because of that he gets more air time
than anybody else.
By far,
I mean it's not even close.
All the other guys in the Republican,
the Republican candidates,
they were all playing second fiddle.
They were all trying to catch up.
They were even trying to do his thing
like Marco Rubio was making fun of his
hands and what does he do?
He turns into a big Dick joke.
She's like,
don't want my.
I'm fine in that department.
Don't want right.
I'm fine in that department,
and everybody's like,
Hey,
he's holding it.
He's talking about his dick.
This is amazing,
and it got him even more fans.
I think people are tired of what the
game is right now.
What the is right now.
As a guy gets on a podium,
he says a bunch of things that you know
and I know will fucking never happen.
Obama,
everybody was hope and change.
Hope and change.
He's going to close Guantanamo Bay.
He's going to get us out of Iraq.
He's going to get us out of Afghanistan.
We're still in Iraq.
We're still in Afghanistan.
Guantanamo base.
Still here.
No hope.
No change.
Drones are everywhere.
We're gonna.
Let whistle blowers off the hook.
Bullshit.
Cracks down on whistle blowers more than
anybody.
More military than George W Bush.
Okay?
More more attacks on free press than any
Republican,
a republican president,
but because he doesn't under the guise
of being on the left,
people don't look at the cold hard
reality of his actions.
Yeah,
so it's a bullshit fucking scam.
So this guy comes along and he plays it
like a pro wrestler.
He plays it like a reality TV star.
He plays it like a guy who is savvy
about the media.
He's been working the media his whole
career and it's working.
Yeah.
No,
I love it.
And to your point,
he is running his presidential campaign
the way Vince Mcmahon would promote a
wrestle mania and he's getting
attention.
He's evoking any emotion.
Front row.
Brian actually told me that.
Who's watching right now?
He keeps texting me so quick.
Shout out to him.
I'm stealing his line,
but he's right about that and he's
evoking emotion.
He's getting people involved.
He understands that ratings are what get
you on TV.
He understands he can save money for
that.
He's also refused to take donations.
He doesn't want to be.
Body wants everybody to understand that
he's going to go in free and clear and
oh,
nobody anything but,
but he wouldn't,
but wait a minute.
He just requested a bunch of donut.
He took it back,
but he.
But Joe,
he was very candid about it.
He said,
I have been funding this myself any
scent,
and frankly I haven't gotten a very good
return.
I'm funding this myself so everybody
knows I'm not button sold that I haven't
made deals that I'm going to go in there
and actually represent the paypal.
I'm going to take a pay cut.
I'm going to go do a job.
I don't want to do it because it's a job
I think I need to do.
That message didn't get out and he said,
look,
I'm losing in the polls to somebody who
is bought and paid for because she's got
more money than me.
You people don't seem to understand this
message of me going in there not owing
anybody anything.
I haven't got an investment on my return
and I'm thinking about taking it back
and open it up today.
He,
but he was very honest about it.
He was very candid.
I thought he had like an emergency
drive.
He did and he just.
He pulled the back.
No,
no,
no.
What I'm saying.
You had the emergency drought,
but that was interesting too.
He said,
I want to raise $10,000,000 in two days,
and by the way,
if you guys give me 10,
I'll throw another tenant on myself.
So he ended up matching.
He put 20 million and then he did it
again.
It was such a success.
He did it again.
Well,
it's,
it's a weird situation for the Democrats
because if Hillary did get indicted and
if Hillary did wind up getting
convicted,
are they punished her in any way?
It's over.
That's hides over.
Right.
So who else is there?
Bernie Sanders.
They don't want that,
right?
Nobody wants that.
That's just crazy old socialists.
A lot of a lot of people is Vermont.
She's picking up a Elizabeth Warren as
her running mate.
No,
I don't think so.
I think she's cognizant enough
to know that America does not want to
look sexist,
but it in fact is that America is going
to have a hard time putting a female as
the commander and chief of the military
who doesn't come out and endorse
anybody,
but if you talk to them privately,
they do not want to be led by a woman.
That's a reality.
I think she's smart enough to know they
damn sure don't want to be led by two
but there,
but.
But of course would never say that
publicly.
Right.
We don't want to look sexist as a
country even though we are.
If Hillary wants to put the nail in the
coffin of this campaign,
she puts.
Bill is our VP.
She does not have an ego that would
allow her to do such and I think she
might make the air of putting Elizabeth
warning.
Man,
that would be a weird thing because
Elizabeth Warren pretended that she was
native American.
Yeah.
She lied.
Straight up lie and that's racist.
No way around that whole cultural
appropriation.
That's a big thing today.
There's no way around that one.
She should've did and then what she
commented on her.
Well,
my eyes look this way.
She,
yeah,
it got bad.
It got bad and trump instead of just.
Instead of saying it the way you use it,
well you know you lied about me.
He called her pocahontas,
Pocahontas.
Everybody says that's.
He says it more will.
He calls Bernie Sanders crazy.
Bernie called Hillary Lion.
Hillary.
Crooked,
crooked,
Crooked Hillary.
That's smart.
I mean,
look what he does by labeling them and
then a white lion.
Ted.
That's great.
It's wrestling me.
He gave me the ball.
He didn't.
He gave them all a gimmick.
Well,
he juked the system.
The system was based on deception the
first place and they had this whole
standard operation.
The way they would run things,
they would all do it the exact same way
and he came in and exposed all the flaws
in the game.
Yeah.
And he's not done and he's not backing
off and everybody keeps waiting in the
backyard it because it's not the real
presidential candidate.
I mean,
it's not the real campaign yet.
The real campaign begins once.
It is absolutely hillary and absolutely
him and it gets boiled down,
like right now we're in July when it
gets to be August and then September,
that's when Shit's gonna really start
flying and you know it's going to be
interesting to see what he uses to try
to attack her and what she used to try
to attack him and how both there they're
both going to get damaged in the process
and our system is going to be damaged in
the process and that's something that I
think everybody is kind of cognizant of
when you destroy someone who is on their
way to become the commander and chief,
you kind of weak in the whole nation
because that person becomes the like,
look,
if Hillary won,
say if the elections were tomorrow and
the FBI thing happened today and then
she winds tomorrow and everybody's going
to be like,
Ooh,
we know she did something that we would
have been punished for.
How is this weakens the position and it
weakens it in the eyes of the world too.
I'm sure
it does.
It does.
When we talk about vp picks,
I'm not sure that they've got to write.
The media thinks they've got it narrowed
down to four guys and they added one
more for trump on trump's side.
Christy and Gingrich and pence and
they've.
They've got five and I don't think
they're right.
I think that he will go outside the box.
He's not going to put a woman in there
just just to put a vagina on the ticket
and think he's going to do like mccain
did with
Pailin.
I think he's going to bring in somebody
that's either got admiral or colonel or
general next to their name.
I think that it is very important for
him to look powerful and be powerful and
I think he wants a military guy and I
think that's who he admires.
I don't think he admires politicians.
I think he admires soldiers.
That would be interesting if he did that
and that would be a huge step up if he
did do that and in in,
in terms of like how public responded to
him because if he's like the big
showman,
but he's got some very serious guy with
some real world experience as his second
guy,
that would be a really interesting.
It's just to me,
it's just disturbing that we're down to
a reality TV star and an old lady trying
to get back at her husband for a blow
job.
He got in the nineties show.
The whole thing is
disturbing Bill Clinton tree to the
White House like it was a frat and I
will forever appreciate that.
I just will.
I just.
Well,
I mean he was a mess.
He was all these different.
He was unapologetic.
He was the master liar member.
The divisible in the not denominator and
he was going in all these circles and
before you're done,
you just flat out confused,
man.
That Oxford degree really sent me in
circles.
I guess we give this guy a pass.
He's an odd dude,
man.
He's a very odd dude and he still swing
and he's still swinging out there for
his wife.
Yeah.
And See,
that's another one though,
Joe,
if you don't mind me interrupting,
if he would've just told the truth back
then,
just use the truth on a site.
It would have all been done if he
would've just said,
man,
I'll sleep with anything in the world
except her.
If he would've just done that,
it'd be all over and said he started
getting crazy.
If he would've hit them with that line.
You know,
it's the same thing.
It's the same thing with,
uh,
with trump right now.
If he would have just said,
look,
I think that America should have a long
leash,
but attached to that Leisha is a big old
bomb and this is how we're going to do
it and we'll light the thing if we have
to.
It's hard to deal with.
It's really hard to deal with.
I got all of this,
this philosophy from you giving me your
take on how Michael Richards should have
handed the comedy store.
When you said he should've come out,
he should have said,
here's my problems.
I'm not a funny comic.
Okay.
I was self conscious.
You guys made me feel bad.
I wanted to hurt your feelings.
Had nothing to do with race.
I tried to hurt your feelings and you're
right.
It all would have gone away because we
go,
yeah,
that,
that is what happened.
You know,
it is what happened.
But,
and that's precisely with Charlie Sheen
did when Charlie Sheen came out and he
said,
look,
this is how I roll.
I smoke rocks,
I pay girls to leave.
I don't pay him to have sex.
And everyone was like,
what the fuck?
What,
what do you say to that?
You can't say anything.
And everybody was Hashtag Tiger blood.
It was all over the.
I mean he became sort of until the HIV
thing came that kind of put an
accountant
that put a damper,
but you're right.
Sheen was the original Shin was the
originalist sat in the hot speed.
Everybody was waiting for the tearful
Jon Jones style apology and it did not
come.
She huge because it ended up doing a
comedy or a an appearance tour,
whatever he saw.
He did seven and a half million dollars
in tickets on a two week tour because of
that one sit down where he refused to
apologize.
Why I like to party.
I didn't even have any comedy.
He didn't know what to do,
so he went to these things coked up
thinking he was just going to power
through it with charisma and people were
bu in and people and he's like,
Hey,
I got your money.
I already got your money,
which is fucking crazy
to yell out of people that have bought
your tickets.
But then he adjusted.
He got smart and you brought guys like
Russell Peters in to sit down with them
and interview him and they actually
worked out a routine and it actually
became an entertaining show towards the
last leg of the tour.
But his ability to step up and say,
hey,
I like coke.
I like to smoke coke.
I get together.
I get a bunch of girls.
I pay him money.
I fucked up and then they leave and
everybody's like,
well,
because that's what everybody's always
avoided to catch someone always doing
trucks like prostitute.
The cover up is always worse than the
crime.
Again,
you go back to John Jones,
John Jones gets tagged in that coke
thing.
He pops on Fox and the and the woman
asks him why he did it and that was Sam
Johnson.
Well,
you know,
but any,
any try to dance around.
He had his pocket of.
I did it to get high.
Next question.
Stupid.
Yeah.
That's it.
So,
yeah,
it was funny.
I was at a party having a good time.
I didn't know you're going to test me,
right?
That's the answer.
But use the truth on your side is just,
it just shuts everybody down and it's,
it's endearing and refreshing.
Well,
this,
this current thing that he's on right
now,
um,
I wonder if he can do that with this.
I mean,
I wonder if he knows what it was that he
took.
You know,
I mean,
I just don't know.
I know I'm,
I'm really,
I'm confused by this one because I don't
know how many different options there
could have been where these are the two
things that he tested positive for.
I don't know how many options there
could have been other than him taking
that because he was getting off
steroids,
but that doesn't even seem to make sense
because he had been tested like much
more recently or before that,
like we're close to that and he didn't
have that in his system and he didn't
have steroids in a system.
But to victor context credit,
Victor Conte did question.
Jon Jones is a testosterone levels and
EPA testosterone levels before carbon
isotope tents.
Yes.
Yeah,
and they were for Gazy.
What could cause that at various same.
All you're going to do is confuse people
when you start talking about that,
and frankly you can't get doctors to
totally agree.
Even with Sada,
with their highest scientists and
everything there.
There's some confusion there.
There was something for gazy going on,
but it wasn't enough.
It was just enough to start rumors not
to actually take him in and,
and go against him.
But you know,
you glossed over what I opened the show
with and I thought it was going to be
one of the high points of the whole
podcast.
I didn't know if you had to do it.
No,
not the cop.
I don't know if you had this,
so I don't mean to go back to it,
but the point that this test that we're
all talking about is June 16th and there
could.
There's got to be another shoe that's
getting ready to drop now.
Whether that comes back hot or what it
comes back clean,
we don't know,
but there is no way that Assad sought
last time testing a guy for a fight that
was supposed to take place this last
Saturday.
It was June 60.
There's just no way.
They've got to be at least another test
out there and possibly to brock lesnar.
They test him every other day for stuff
five
times within the first two weeks.
That was in the first two weeks.
Eight times.
Same thing.
They did the same thing to her.
They tested her a ton of times.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean we.
This is just speculation,
right?
We really won't know and I'm sure we'll
find
out shortly because those tests take a
while to get the results back because
they're very,
very thorough and if he tested June
16th,
you've got to assume big,
high profile,
UFC 200.
And the guy was already tested positive
for some time before.
So they're gonna.
They're gonna be sneaking around trying
to catch him.
What was the crazy story where he went?
He was hiding.
Is that true?
I wasn't there.
I'll tell the story.
All right,
let's tell the story.
Assata came in and it gives us,
by the way,
this is a legend.
It is,
yeah.
Story.
The story.
But uh,
this from some,
some of those teammates,
UFC fighters that claimed they were
there,
but that.
And that doesn't make it true.
Myfi guys tired of him beating the fuck
out of them.
All the disclaimers aside.
Let's get down to the entertainment side
of this.
So solder rolls in to Jackson's gym to
do a test on John Jones and there was
only some coaches in there.
And John,
if there was like five people there at
the time so he can see them coming.
They where they parked,
he can see them coming so they don't
know what to do with them.
They hide them underneath the cage.
They hired John John tides up to the
cage.
They tell John we don't know where he is
and this is before we were enrolled in
the program and he did not need to
disclose his whereabouts.
At the same time,
if they show up and find you,
you must tap vandelay this situation,
you must test.
They can't find you.
You didn't have to test back this.
So anyway you hides under the ring.
They said,
well where is he supposed to?
You know,
this is Jim.
They said,
well how would I know where he is?
So instead of leaving like they thought
they would,
do they take a seat?
Well there's like eight hours left in
the business day.
They don't ever leave.
However,
along with six to eight hour timeframe,
John's under the cage the entire time.
So people are coming and going the whole
thing.
And finally they shut the lights off and
go to lock the doors.
Now John can come out.
What we found out about that and they
want it.
They didn't do this.
They wanted to get a warrant and go
under that ring under the theory that at
some point in that six to eight hour
span,
he would've had a pee where they wanted
to go under forensically and collect
that urine.
That's how upset they were that they had
been had.
Now I realize that we're saying all the
nice to have a that happened.
How long was the timeframe and all of
that,
that part.
That part's coming after him.
After that,
when they found out that they had been
to anything they hate,
they don't like when people say their
test doesn't work and they don't like
being duped and they came after.
I remember when I predicted rumbled,
Jones will not happen.
Yes you did.
That's because I had that story and I
knew soda was looking for him.
I knew they had boots on the ground in
albuquerque waiting for him to lead the
club late and for it to get him for
anything.
I was armed with that.
I've never told that.
So that's why I predict that fight.
What had happened,
I knew they were after him and this is
before we had to do the whereabouts like
we do now.
Back then it was just random and they
had people,
they were just waiting.
They were just waiting for the right
time and they were going to grab him.
Wow.
To get a.
If they got a warrant to check
underneath the well,
how would they prove that it was his
pee?
That's a lot of fighters or dirty.
There's a lot of problems,
you know,
just in just
like,
just to show support.
They could all just whip their dicks out
and pea underneath the cage.
Yeah,
sure.
I mean if you really love the guy,
pollute the water better yet,
Joe,
you go under and you clean underneath
the cage.
That would also solve the problem,
but it turns out John's pregnant.
Look right,
get under there and yeah,
it was just a mess,
but yeah,
that's,
that's could be anybody's urine.
There you go.
Yeah.
It wasn't.
I mean,
that's a great story though.
It's one of the great all time of
avoiding a drug test story.
Sure.
Maybe the best,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
you came out here to promote a
submission grappling thing to it.
Yeah.
We got a big thing coming up a Sunday
this coming Sunday,
yet July 17th.
Live and free on flow combat and you've
got to be a member,
right?
That's,
that's the trick.
Sell to it,
but you're not buying a paper review
window.
You get,
you just get a monthly subscription.
There's flow combat,
combat.com.
F fellow.
That's right.
FL,
low combat.
Thank you for correcting me on that.
Ebi Rules,
Eddie Bravo.
Invitational rules that they'll go for
eight minutes.
There's no score.
You either find a submission or you
don't.
If you don't,
you go into an overtime format.
Now you know how Ebi Works and this is
the biggest promotion of the whole
thing,
isn't that somebody is going to go out
and compete and I got to do some
grappling since I've been retired,
but we all,
we always had a clause that if you could
eat up the clock,
you've got to draw.
Nobody loses.
Whether that's a victory.
Sometimes when you're in over your head,
you're up there wrestling for a draw.
When I had a vow that was out there
wrestling for a draw under Ebi rules,
somebody is going to tap.
So when you factor in,
you've got jake shields taken on.
Chris Lidell,
one of those guys is going to tap when
you've got vinny Mongolians,
maybe the best grappler there is right
now.
Mega lays.
He always corrects me on that too.
I feel like it's tomato,
tomato,
vinny Mokuleia.
And so I said,
uh,
you know he's going to be taken on.
Ronnie marks.
King Mo got hurt.
He hurt his neck.
Ronnie marks has now stepped in.
He fought.
You were here?
Yeah.
Chemo hurt his neck.
King Modena pulled out.
I pulled him off the card.
I found out he was hurt,
it happened in,
in his fight with Phil Davis and he's,
he's one of the main training partners
for Robbie lawler and he hasn't even
been able to train with Robbie.
I ran into Labario.
Uh,
you want to correct me on that name for
you?
Thank you.
Ran into Laborio over the weekend at
the,
at the super show.
And uh,
he said,
man,
King,
Mo King,
Mo can't move.
He just doesn't.
He doesn't want to pull out herniated
disc.
Yeah.
Something like that.
I don't have all the details,
but I got to hold them all.
I said,
is this true?
He said,
yeah,
I'm going to come to so many guys a
fucked up next.
Yeah,
we got to pull that one.
Sohani marks is in.
He fought you.
El Ramiro.
Erin Simpson.
Do you remember those?
He just signed with world series of
fighting a Sohani Zen against vinny.
And then the biggest one,
the absolute biggest one that wasn't
meant to be,
but this is the one that's got my phone
ringing.
Rico Rodrigues is coming back after all
these years.
He's going to take on [inaudible] or
sharing,
or my coach,
he's going to take on my coach and one
of them is going to tap into.
They will not leave until someone tells
slot in the UFC back in the day.
He's a excellent Brazilian Jujitsu
practitioner.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
Matter.
Rico is a bad motherfucker,
man.
His ground game is very good.
He's fantastic.
And then the question with Rico,
Joe,
you know,
grappling is a gateway into mma.
So now that Rico's all of a sudden back
in grappling,
that's everybody's big question,
is he coming back to mma and he's one of
those guys that left the sport on his
own.
There wasn't that a promoter when it
sign them or Dana didn't want them or
pride wouldn't put them under contract.
He had those personal right.
He did whatever,
but he left on his own.
It's kind of the way Sean Sherk left.
Sean's just one day.
It wasn't fighting anymore,
but it took like two years until the
announcement came.
It just makes me wonder is Ricoh coming
back?
And I think that that's pretty cool.
If he is.
It's very rare where a world champion
returns that speculation,
but let's see what happens.
Well,
it's an interesting matchup either way
and so this is something you're doing
for the first time on flow combat and
you said that they have to become a
member,
like what does that entail?
Giving up your email address or
something?
Yeah,
you go over,
you register a flow combat.com.
I think it's like 15 bucks a month.
14 95.
It's a network though.
It's kind of like fight pass.
There's.
There's content,
there's behind the scenes.
It's a whole network,
so you're not going to buy a paper view
window that then shuts off.
You become a member and then you can
turn that off the next day.
You can turn it off at the end of the
month.
You're going to buy for the month,
so you get an entire package.
They've got a ton of members.
He's a real successful guys,
so it's Kinda just to satisfy them.
The show soul that's completely sold out
in Portland.
It.
It'll be,
in my mind,
the biggest grappling of whenever I've
done metamorris.
Metamorris was sold out,
but they had 700 tickets.
This is a lot more tickets sold out.
The only way to watch will be on flow
combat.com.
So the guys that are participating are
going to have a lot of fun.
I did some grappling.
I just took out Michael Bisping in a,
in a grappling match.
Roy Jones was on the car.
It was this crazy car to uh,
we wrestled in Arizona like the week
after he beat Anderson.
This just happened really?
But nobody came.
So people were like,
you,
they didn't even know what was going on.
Oh,
I had heard about Roy Jones boxing some
fan,
but fought a fan that goes five and
three and mma,
a two window,
an amateur boxing.
And he gave Roy a match.
He get Roy met.
Roy figured about bumble,
shut them off.
Well,
this is a boy had been knocked out
brutally just a couple of months ago I
think in Russia or Germany.
And fight was.
Yeah,
that was,
I was awful.
Yeah.
Roy is staying busy though.
You know,
I just hate to see them take punishment
because he was such a great fighter.
So good.
It's just,
it's so sad to see him now.
His body just looks doughy.
He doesn't look good.
You know,
he's still an excellent commentator
though.
I mean,
it's not.
It's not effecting the wheat talks.
Right?
That is true.
Yeah.
It was good to see Roy.
But the point was,
you know,
that you had a limited amount of people
there.
So in grappling events and then
metamorris now,
or at least for the last one,
they've got a show coming up too,
but the last one they had,
we wrestle in front of nobody.
I was kind of ended that.
But the point is you grapplers like
people there.
I just kinda like that opposite field
from going into a packed arena to that
field.
Get more of a practice room atmosphere
at any rate with Kuma Tay,
now that you're correcting all my words,
is that what I'm trying to say?
This one sold out.
So the grapplers are going to wrestle.
They're going to have a roaring audience
and it's a rare thing.
Well,
the Eddie Bravo rules,
Eddie Bravo invitation rules are without
a doubt the best rules because they
force guys in a bad
situation.
So what it is is after the fight goes to
the would you have eight minutes,
eight minutes after it goes through the
eight minute timed difference in there's
a draw.
What happens is you put guys in bad
positions,
so just like in wrestling,
one guy will start on the bottom in
Jujitsu,
what they're doing with Eddie Bravo
rules is one guy will start on your back
or he'll start in a position called
spiderweb,
which means you're defending.
You got the guy in the bottoms defending
against an art bar.
The guy on the top is inside control
with the arm hooked and controlling the
leg.
So it's a bad spot to be in if you're on
the bottom and it's a bad spot.
If a guy obviously has your back.
So by putting guys in those situations,
you will allow the fight or to try to
work from a really bad spot to try to
get a tap.
And then you switched places.
So if you started on my back and you tap
me,
then I have at least an opportunity to
try to tap you and if you escaped and
you wind up winning the whole thing,
but it could be that you escape,
escape,
and we see a lot of those matches where
it's like down to the wire and if that's
the case then he count up the amount of
time spent in control.
So if it takes you 10 seconds to escape,
but it takes me 30 seconds to escape,
you would win because you escaped
quicker,
right?
That's exactly right.
It's a great way to figure out how to
make grappling matches.
Excited.
I talked to Eddie before we went into
this and I said,
hey listen,
we're doing.
What are you doing?
We're getting.
We can fall in the same day.
It's how do you want to do this?
You know,
let's not get a battle with each other.
He goes,
no,
no.
Just the opposite.
He said,
I want these guys to have somewhere to
wrestle.
He said,
but she'll do this.
Take my rules,
call it Abi.
That puts me up,
but he goes,
but do it,
and he had a great point,
Joel,
here's what his point was.
He said,
you know,
everybody that has a grappling event
wants to make up their own rules.
He said,
but as an industry for the gym owners,
for the guys that are going into the gym
and they're training everyday,
they need to be able to train the same
way the coach needs to be able to have a
stopwatch just like he does mma.
Five minute rounds.
You do three of them.
If you're a man of intertidal fight,
you do five of you go to a basketball
court,
you go volume.
It's the same universal rules.
He said,
for an industry,
we need to be all teammates,
all Nogi Jujitsu.
They need to be able to train the same
way so the coach can run a practice and
it doesn't have to go.
You guys train to fraud Vodavi over here
and you guys train them for the Ibj f
over here and you get.
So I thought,
Eddie,
you're right.
If us promoters can all get together and
unify some rules,
like the unified rules of MMA as an
industry,
the trickle down,
which is the gyms,
we could get this thing figured out and
then we can start to have a hybrid and
Eddie's rules really are quite perfect.
You know,
he calls them the most gangster rules
out there,
but he's right.
I talked to Vinnie,
I talked to some other guys that I
talked to.
I talked to Sala Rivera.
They're going,
look,
it's Ebi.
That's how you find if you want to live
the best is you got to go.
Ebi Rules.
Yeah.
It really is the best and it stops all
these draws.
These draws are brutal.
I mean you have that a polaris match.
You got all these amazing matchups and
then Gary Tonin verses Paul Harris,
draw other.
Fuck.
You haven't draws.
Everything is a draw,
draw,
draw.
You can have people get excited about
draws.
They don't get excited about draws.
That's not fun.
I talked to her about that and how it
goes.
You know,
I do have.
I do have one problem with that.
He said,
I guys are more,
I can get them to,
to wrestle more guys kinda like that,
that clause,
and you got to have a time limit
somewhere and we don't quite know how to
figure out the overtime yet.
He said,
but the problem I'm running into is I
want to champion.
He said,
and it's hard to build a division and to
decide who's the next number one
contender if you don't have an
architecture in place where a guy
advances through a bracket,
if you will,
you have to have.
You have to have a winter,
right?
Yeah.
That is a giant issue with,
uh,
everybody else's rule set.
I just think that if you look at
submission grappling and especially
people that have a problem with the
quote unquote violence of MMA,
the submission aspect of it is,
it's beautiful to watch.
It's exciting,
it's dynamic and you watch someone get
choked out.
It's crazy.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's really interesting.
It's fun.
It's a,
it's an exciting part of martial arts
and it's something that guys can do when
they retire from fighting.
It's something that a lot of people that
don't want to get involved in mma,
but guys like the Mendez brothers or
there's a Gary Turner,
he's actually probably going to do mma
eventually,
but all these super talented grapplers
it gives them an opportunity to show
their stuff.
Yeah,
certainly.
I love that.
You know who Tony is,
by the way.
You know,
he's so excited.
He's crazy.
Oh yeah.
Turn it on.
Yeah,
he's.
Yeah.
He's just.
He's fantastic.
But you've got so many guys like this.
You know,
if you dangle that big carrot and all of
a sudden you're just signing the most
popular and the most famous guys.
It's kind of tough.
I really liked the Olympic model or even
the NCAA model.
The best guy always steps forward,
but the best guy,
a lot of times it has a hard time
getting a chance.
Promoters want guys that are going to
sell.
It's like,
let's put that on hold.
If you're a good promoter,
you'll figure out how to sell.
You just will.
If you're a promoter,
use Dana's.
You'll bring in the bells and whistles,
but let's give everybody a chance the
same way the Olympics Games does.
You know,
lets anybody that thinks they're best.
Raise your hand.
Let's get an error figured out.
Now we're gonna.
Have to have a lot of events.
We're gonna have to work,
but let's get a system in place and
let's figure it out.
Boom.
So instead of rules Ebi,
what is your event called?
It is called submission underground.
It can be found@flowcombat.com.
It's free to all members.
What is this?
What does this video?
Let's play this video and let's end on
this video and anything more to tell
people.
I'm your son in ch on instagram a chain.
What does it entail and on?
On twitter.
Absolutely.
Facebook,
all that gentleman.
Yes.
Thank you for the plug.
Bruce.
Bruce buffer was going to announce the
show.
He.
He fell on his acl as acl.
Yeah.
He was doing a lip sync competition.
Yes.
And apparently he got up,
he gutted it out and he tried to keep
going and they tipped over sideways and
fell over again.
It's hilarious.
Sad.
Want Bruce to get better?
Very funny.
Unfortunate is the second time he blew
his knee out.
Doing that too.
By the way,
he blew his knee out.
That jumped that.
He does.
When he does that,
he leaps in the air.
He blew his acl out.
Doing that.
Wants to watch them live out of the
ring.
This is his second acl surgery.
So it's,
it's a fucking hard job folks.
Okay.
Alright.
Chael and ladies and gentlemen,
and we'll end with this son and
submission underground.
Again.
Flow.
What does that mean?
Backflow.
Calm,
calm,
calm.com.
And it is this
July 17th live and free for all members
and we'll tweet it.
It'll be on my twitter,
so I'll let you guys know in advance.
Thank you brother.
Always great to have you on.
And anytime you want to come on again,
open invitation.
Let's,
let's play it
son and,
and I am here to speak to you about the
pathetic state of affairs in today's
grappling competition.
When grapplers come with promotions,
bring these guys.
They're not sending their best.
They're boring,
they're dull,
they're not risk takers.
I am going to change all of that.
No more 20 minute matches where it can
end in a draw.
What kind of atmosphere is in a drop?
This is anti-competition one set of
rules.
Somebody must win and somebody must
lose.
Guys,
this is America.
We don't go to draw.
We play for keeps.
We play for somebody to get their hand
raised.
Guys,
if you don't know,
you damn sure should know.
On July 17th,
submission underground is invading
Portland.
Oregon's Roseland theater.
Now tickets are sold out,
but you still got a chance.
Go to your desktop,
grab your smartphone,
send a pigeon,
send a fax if you have to,
let your friends know.
Don't be left in the dark Monday morning
around the water cooler.
Don't be the only person that didn't
witness history.
Go to flow combat.com.
God bless America.
Goodnight everybody.
That's a genius.